chers collègues
bonjour nous avons le plaisir
aujourd'hui de recevoir Monsieur Jean
Maurice Ripert ambassadeur de France
vous avez été ambassadeur en Russie
d'abord puis en Chine
je vous remercie Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
de vous être rendu disponible pour notre
audition je vous prie de m'excuser pour
l'annulation que vous avez subi il y a
quelques jours qui était dû à une grippe
soudaine et virulente qui m'a frappé je
n'ai pas eu le temps de passer les
responsabilités un des vices précédents
et donc nous n'avons pas pu vous
recevoir et je vous prie de m'en excuser
parce que j'imagine que vous avez comme
beaucoup de personnes que nous auditions
nous auditionnons pardon des un agenda
chargé donc je vous remercie de vous
être libéré dans un délai très
raisonnable cette audition contrairement
à beaucoup d'auditions que notre
commission réalisée n'est pas en huis
clos elle est retransmise en direct sur
le site de l'Assemblée nationale
l'enregistrement vidéo sera ensuite
disponible à la demande je précise que
naturellement aller aussi ouverte à la
presse qui est présente dans la salle
comme vous le savez Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur nous cherchons avec cette
commission d'enquête parlementaire a
cerner à comprendre précisément la
réalité des faits d'ingérence
d'influence hostile de puissance
étrangère notamment dans la vie
politique française mais aussi plus
largement dans les relais d'opinion qui
peuvent influencer nos compatriotes mais
aussi les décideurs économiques or le
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que les
déclarations que vous avez faites sur
LCI mi-septembre 2022 évoqué des faits
potentiellement très graves qui concerne
pleinement notre commission vous n'êtes
pas non plus en savoir que suite à vos
déclarations à nos collègues députés a
fait un signalement je crois que c'est
aussi au procureur oui au procureur et
que cette enchaînement de conséquence a
participé à la motivation pour le groupe
moi je le dis en toute transparence pour
le groupe rassemblement national à
l'exercice de son droit de tirage pour
clarifier ses preuves non pas vos
propres en particulier mais d'une
manière générale cette question des
ingérences dans la vie politique
française puisque nous considérons
évidemment que les ingérences et les
soupçons d'ingérences sont des poisons
qui menacent nos démocraties comme les
ont menacées directement indirectement
des démocraties voisines je rappelle
pour la bonne compréhension de ce qui
nous écoutent les propos vous pourrez
revenir dessus évidemment que vous avez
tenu ce jour-là à l'antenne j'ouvre les
guillemets personne n'ignorait qu'un
certain nombre d'hommes et de femmes
politiques français d'un certain bord
venaient à Moscou enfin c'est moi qui
rajoute venez à Moscou je reprends les
guillemets et ne reportez pas les mains
vides donc évidemment nous souhaiterions
que vous expliciez les propos vous
pouvez d'ailleurs avoir avoir une
citation plus extensive si vous le
souhaitez évidemment puisque ces propos
ont contribué et contribué encore
aujourd'hui à entretenir un soupçon sur
tout ou partie de la classe politique
française donc on voit savoir si vous
pouviez revenir sur ces propos les
expliciter nous informer informer la
représentation parlementaire de qui de
qui vous étiez concerné à la fois
d'ailleurs qui était concerné par les
accusations que vous avez portées mais
aussi qui était ce on que enfin tout le
monde ce tout le monde tout le monde qui
savait puisque vous avez aussi ajouté
ensuite que ces informations étaient
connues d'un grand nombre de personnes
cette audition évidemment ne se limite
pas à cette à cette déclaration dans la
presse ce serait évidemment mais
connaître votre expérience et ce que
vous pouvez apporter à la commission
nous aimerions aussi avoir votre
expérience de votre poste en Russie des
réseaux que vous avez pu avoir à
connaître qui intéresse notre commission
de l'évolution du régime russe de sa
stratégie envers notre pays et d'une
manière générale envers les démocraties
et nos alliés sur la thématique
évidemment de l'ingérence de l'influence
de l'interférence mais vous avez été
aussi en poste apk entre 2017 et 2019
donc en République populaire de Chine là
aussi pays nous l'avons bien vu que les
travaux de notre commission dont les
tentatives d'ingérence et d'influence
sont évidemment au cœur de notre travaux
et donc nous aimerions aussi avoir votre
témoignage sur votre expérience sur ce
régime et enfin votre expérience en tant
que décideur responsable français de
l'autre côté de votre perception de
l'état de la démocratie en France de
notre capacité à résister à ces
tentatives ou cette réalité d'ingérence
étrangère vous aurez la parole Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur pour une intervention
liminaire si possible d'une quinzaine de
minutes après quoi vous serez interrogé
par votre serviteur par Madame la
rapporteur et par les commissaire
présent je vous rappelle enfin Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur qu'aux titres de l'article
6 de l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires les personnes
auditionnées par une commission
d'enquête doivent prêter serment de dire
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité aussi Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je
vous invite à lever la main droite et à
dire je le jure
je vous remercie et je vous laisse la
parole pour votre intervention limitée
merci monsieur le Président et merci à
la commission d'avoir demandé un montant
de sur le sujet général des ingérences
étrangères qui me paraît extrêmement
important
donc je pense à titre personnel que il a
été trop longtemps
ignoré ou en tout cas minorer et je me
réjouis que la représentation nationale
s'y attache je précise que je précise
tout de suite que je ne suis pas un
décideur je suis un fonctionnaire
retraité ce qui n'est pas tout à fait la
même chose et donc je voudrais préciser
à cet égard que mes seules activités
depuis septembre 2019 consiste à
présider des associations et des ONG qui
s'occupent de développement et notamment
de protection des droits humains et en
particulier les filles et que par
ailleurs je représente l'État dans deux
institutions France médiumonde et
le comité éthique et scientifique de
l'agence vigilum donc ça tombe assez
bien puisque je sais que vous avez
auditionné son directeur ainsi que le
secrétaire général à la défense et à la
sécurité nationale
donc je n'ai que des activités bénévoles
je ne suis en rien un décideur je suis
encore une fois un fonctionnaire à la
retraite et j'ai observé pendant au
moins deux ans une diète médiatique
absolument quasiment totale donc j'ai
respecté les règles de l'éthique pour
évoquer la première question évidemment
je m'y attendais
vous avez cité correctement une
déclaration que j'ai faite soit un
dimanche soir à LCI donc peut-être je
n'ai pas totalement maîtrisée le
conditionnel mais je maintiens les
propos que j'ai tenus
comme je dis d'un certain bord vous
voulez savoir à qui je me réfère je
pensais s'agissant de la Russie je
précise bien il s'agissant de cette
phrase de représentant de l'ancien parti
qui s'appelait le Front national alors
quand je dis on je n'implique pas la
planète évidemment je dis simplement que
ce sujet des ingérences étrangères et
des ingérences de Moscou en tout cas de
d'activité d'influence assez forte était
un sujet de discussion entre nous les
ambassadeurs et en particulier entre
ambassadeurs de l'Union européenne parce
que c'était un sujet qui nous
préoccupait et que nous nous posions la
question de savoir comment nous étions
le mieux armé un pour en rendre compte à
nos autorités et deux pour
éventuellement contribuer à notre place
d'ambassadeurs sur place
à la lutte contre ces
tentative d'influence ma ligne ou pas
donc quand je faisais référence à 11 je
faisais référence à plusieurs
ambassadeurs de l'Union européenne quant
à savoir pourquoi j'ai dit cela je l'ai
dit en septembre dernier je crois ou en
novembre je ne sais plus très bien
j'ai du pardon en septembre donc après
qu'un certain nombre de fêtes aient été
rendu public
contenterait à cet égard de rappeler les
déclarations de l'actuel président de la
République lors de la campagne
électorale et notamment tout ce qui
touchaient auprès obtenu par le Front
national d'une banque tchéco russe avec
évidemment la valve du Kremlin et des
autorités russes tout cela est connu et
public
quant à son caractère
non pas uniquement bancaire et j'ai
envie de dire je peux me référer aussi
un des déclarations faites face caméra
au mois d'octobre de 2022
pour l'émission complémentaires de
France 2 par Monsieur Jean-Luc chaffozer
ancien député du Front National au
Parlement européen qui a dit je cite à
peu près je peux pas faire un Verbatim
exprès non Vladimir Poutine ne s'y est
pas opposée s'il n'y aurait pas eu de
près bien sûr j'ai déjà vu pas dire
Poutine est-ce que c'était en présence
de Marine Le Pen je ne vous le dirai pas
la Russie a besoin d'allier elle en
recherche pour Vladimir Poutine le prêt
alors que l'Occident fait la guerre à la
Russie était une façon d'enfoncer un
coin et de soutenir et de soutien un
mouvement qui ne s'y est pas opposé
pardon de soutenir et de un mouvement
qui ne s'y est pas opposé la Russie
conduit ses intérêts
j'ai été un intermédiaire bien entendu
j'ai traité au plus haut niveau au plus
haut niveau a-t-il répété sauf en ma
part en faisant un geste de cet ordre
j'ai été l'intermédiaire dans ce pré
j'ai vu alors le journaliste
l'interrogeait vous auriez touché entre
140000 et 450 000 euros selon les
sources et vous êtes d'ailleurs visé à
ce titre par une enquête du parquet
national financier il a répondu c'est la
date de 2016 je n'ai pas de nouvelles il
n'a donc pas nié avoir touché une
commission face caméra il n'a pas mis à
avoir touché une commission pour obtenir
la négote pour négocier et obtenir ce
prêt
troisièmement je voudrais je m'arrêterai
là parce que sinon ça risque d'être un
petit peu fastidieux je peux vous
renvoyer vous allez être un peu plus
surpris probablement à une déclaration
faite lors d'une audition publique au
bout de stagne par le président des
renseignements intérieurs allemands
Monsieur Thomas ralden Vang j'espère que
je n'écorche pas son nom qui a déclaré
vous pouvez retrouver ça sur le site de
Bundes stag alors je précise que mon
allemand est insuffisant pour avoir
compris tout du premier coup et je me
suis
confié à l'application deep elle qui
fait autorité en mettant de traduction
automatique et il a déclaré ceci les
structures de financement il parlaient
des parties prorus c'est difficile pour
nous d'avoir une vue d'ensemble parce
que nous n'avons pas les outils légaux
pour le faire je précise aussi que c'est
intéressant cette deuxième partie de la
phrase nous pouvons donc recueillir des
impressions ponctuelles l'impression
ponctuelle
et que par le passé des hommes
politiques de différents partis ce sont
parfois rendus à Moscou et ne sont
certainement pas revenu les mains vides
fin de citation
donc je le reconnais j'ai été assez
affirmatif sauf que je portais un
jugement personnel comme le président
comme pardon le directeur des
Renseignements allemands faisaient part
de ses impressions j'ai fait par de mes
impressions j'ai dit que c'était mon
sentiment soyons clairs je n'en ai
évidemment pas la preuve je l'ai
d'ailleurs dit sur un autre plateau si
j'avais eu la preuve j'aurais fait un
article 40 pour déclarer cette
ce fait alors pourquoi est-ce que je
n'en ai pas eu la preuve pour une raison
très simple un ambassadeur c'est un
ambassadeur il est assis dans son bureau
il est sur le terrain il voit des gens
mais ils ne veulent pas à l'aéroport
surtout à Moscou il y a 6 ou 7 vols par
jour interpellé tous les Français qui
arrivent à Moscou pour leur demander ce
qu'il vient de faire
d'abord ce serait illégal ce n'est pas
dans le mandat des ambassadeurs puis
c'est pas aux ambassadeurs de faire ça
ou aux ambassades tout court se rendre à
Moscou n'est pas illégal n'était pas
illégal en tout cas la période où
j'étais ambassadeur rencontré des
autorités russes n'est pas illégale
n'était pas illégale ce que font les
hommes les femmes politiques les
représentants d'associations les
directeurs d'entreprises les
influenceurs les médias dans le bureau
des autorités russes qu'elle rencontrait
je ne peux le savoir que quand j'y étais
associé
mon ambassade est dans toutes les
ambassades où j'ai été ambassadeur et
que ce soit
d'ailleurs pour la France mais aussi
pour les Nations Unies dont j'ai été
secrétaire général adjoint au Pakistan
pendant deux ans un an et demi pardon ou
que ce soit pour l'Union européenne donc
j'ai été l'ambassadeur en Turquie
mon rôle a toujours été de proposer aux
élus qui passaient et notamment bien sûr
au parlementaire mais aussi aux élus des
collectivités locales aux représentants
des syndicats des parties des
associations culturelles et de toutes
les ONG qui le souhaitaient d'avoir un
briefing à l'ambassade de les aider à
organiser leur programme de les soutenir
dans leurs entretiens s'ils le
souhaitaient bien sûr
certains nous invitaient y participer
parce que ça les rassurait parce qu'il
voulait qu'on soit là etc il y a un seul
parti dans mon souvenir en tout cas qui
n'a jamais souhaité prendre contact avec
l'ambassade et qui même une fois à
refuser alors que nous savions qu'il
venait je ne sais pas comment
probablement par une indication de
presse nous avons appelé l'attaché
parlementaire où je ne sais plus très
bien qui pourrait honnête pour dire nous
sommes à votre disposition comme à celle
de tous les élus il nous a été répondu
qu'il n'avait pas besoin de nos services
donc là évidemment je suis dans
l'impossibilité de savoir ce qu'ils y
faisaient ces élus là il y en a sûrement
d'autres qui sont venus sans nous le
dire vous savez Moscou était une grande
ville et je ne vous parle pas de Pékin
le même phénomène s'est reproduit à
Pékin certains élus alors c'était pas le
même parti mais d'autres partis
politiques venaient et ne souhaitez pas
rencontrer l'ambassade c'est la limite
du travail d'un ambassadeur
ce qui veut dire d'ailleurs jean-piète
sur la deuxième partie de votre question
monsieur le Président que les
ambassadeurs parfois n'ont que des
impressions des suspicions qu'il
retirent de leur travail normal
d'ambassadeurs de leur contact de leurs
entretiens mais qu'évidemment de l'un à
avoir des affirmations très claires
c'est difficile donc pour faire court et
résumé il est clair que quand je me suis
adressé j'ai répondu à une question sur
je crois que c'était LCI j'ai fait part
de mon impression personnelle qui s'est
révélée semble-t-il quand même après
l'impression que j'en avais eu assez
juste si j'en crois ce que j'ai lu dans
la presse depuis
sur le problème général des ingérences
monsieur le Président et je vous
remercie d'avoir relevé que j'avais été
ambassade salaire en Russie en Chine je
crois qu'effectivement ce qui est
important c'est de souligner que c'est
un phénomène qui ne touche évidemment
pas que la Russie que toutes les
puissances et j'ai envie de dire
probablement de tout temps à travers
l'histoire tout pays qui poursuivait des
intérêts en dehors de ces frontières
tous les pays ont cherché à influencer
les pays avec lesquels il traitait avec
lesquels ils négociait ou simplement
avec lesquels ils entendaient faire des
affaires mais il y a une évolution qui
me paraît fondamentale et là encore une
fois je ne donne que mon ma lecture à
moi encore une fois je ne suis ni un
intellectuel ni un chercheur ni
universitaire c'est les conclusions
auxquelles je suis parvenu après 41 ans
d'exercices
de la position de diplomate et en
particulier d'ambassadeurs c'est que les
choses ont changé
les choses ont changé ces dernières
années
et les incursions dans notre vie
politique
qu'elle porte contre nos institutions
contre la démocratie en général ce sont
accélérés se sont accrus se sont
exacerbés sont devenus plus violentes
je crois que ça tient à titre personnel
je crois que ça tient à deux phénomènes
la décision des états dirigés par des
régimes autoritaires
de se lancer non seulement dans une
contestation de la démocratie mais de
l'ordre international
et ce refus et ce combat qui est engagé
aujourd'hui avec au premier rang il faut
le dire la Russie et la Chine se traduit
comment par le refus de respecter le
droit international et notamment le
droit humanitaire on le voit tous les
jours dans la guerre en Ukraine c'est
assumé
c'est assumé en Chine puisqu'il est dit
clairement que n'est applicable à la
Chine que le droit je cite le droit au
caractéristique chinoise
il n'y a pas de référence au droit
international et même pas aux
conventions signées par la Chine quant à
l'Ukraine on a vu ce que la Russie devl
Vladimir Poutine je dis bien là aussi de
Vladimir Poutine a fait des traités
qu'elle a signé elle-même pour garantir
l'intégrité territoriale de l'Ukraine et
sa souveraineté je rappelle les méands
de 94 où la Russie était garante du
caractère ukrainien de la Crimée de
Sébastopol
ou les accords entre Léonid kutchmin et
Léonides de Brigitte sur le
démantèlement des armes nucléaires en
Ukraine le partage de la flotte et la
garantie de l'indépendance et de la
souveraineté territoriale de l'Ukraine
c'est la Russie qui a signé ces
documents donc le refus de respecter le
droit international le droit humanitaire
le refus bien sûr de respecter les
droits humains universel
indissociables et imprescriptible
notamment codifié dans la Déclaration
universelle de 1948
dont on va fêter le 75e anniversaire à
la fin de l'année alors il faut bien
comprendre que de mon point de vue en
tout cas pour avoir servi également je
l'ai dit en Turquie et au Pakistan qui
n'étaient pas exactement des modèles de
démocratie à l'époque où j'y étais
il est clair que
un régime autoritaire définit aussi sa
posture à l'international
et sa politique étrangère avec pour
objectif de rester au pouvoir de
consolider son pouvoir et donc traduit
en politique étrangère en général c'est
chouette politique intérieure en tout
cas il serait de mon point de vue naïf
de croire que des pays qui enferment
leurs opposants qui interdisent la
liberté de la presse qui interdisent
toute forme de liberté dans le cas de la
Chine ou à peu près serait plus
bénévolant lorsqu'il s'agit de relations
internationales pourquoi diable
d'où la question qu'on se posera tout à
l'heure de la rationalité
de ceux qui défendent la politique de
ces États notamment en France
ce refus de respecter le droit et
notamment les droits universels et
complété par la contestation des
institutions internationales établies
depuis 45
on l'a vu avec les occupations multiples
de territoires européens par la Russie
parce que je rappelle quand même qu'en
dehors de l'occupation turque de Chypre
Nord la Russie est était déjà avant
l'invasion de février 2022 le seul pays
d'Europe à avoir occupé militairement
des portions de territoire européen la
Russie n'a jamais quitté la Transnistrie
comme vous le savez en 91 la Turquie a
annexé de fait l'ossetti du Sud et la
quasi en Géorgie encore pour la quasi on
peut pas dire qu'ils y soient vraiment
les bienvenus
en 2008
la Crimée et sébastopoles et une partie
du don de base en 2014 et aujourd'hui
l'agression contre l'Ukraine c'est quand
même quelque chose qu'il faut noter et
je rappelle de ce point de vue là c'est
pas une question d'appréciation
personnelle que le secrétaire général
des Nations Unies a déclaré très
rapidement après
l'invasion en février 2022 que cette
invasion était contraire au droit
international et que les annexes
subséquentes étaient illégales
il s'agit aujourd'hui clairement pour la
Russie et la question de la position de
la Chine se posera celle de la Turquie
c'est clair un petit peu heureusement
c'est d'affaiblir la démocratie tout
simplement le combat n'est plus contre
la soi-disante avancée de l'OTAN au
frontières de la Russie mais d'affaiblir
la démocratie juste un point sur la
sur les problèmes de l'OTAN moi je
voudrais rappeler quelque chose en tout
cas qui est fondamental pour moi et qui
explique la différence fondamentale
entre le régime russe et le régime
démocratique et européen notamment c'est
que c'est pas le temps qui s'élargit
c'est la Finlande et la Suède qui
demande à adhérer à l'OTAN ça n'est pas
tout à fait la même chose
ça n'est pas l'Union européenne qui
s'élargit ce sont des États libres et
indépendants et en général démocratique
qui demande à des réunions européenne
c'est évidemment un fait que la Russie a
besoin de faire oublier
en disant que c'est le temps qui avance
et l'Union européenne qui avance et je
souligne un poids tout de suite
important par rapport à votre sujet me
semble-t-il c'est l'appropriation du
langage
un régime autoritaire se fait respecter
notamment en imposant son propre langage
donc la bataille des mots et des
concepts la contestation des mots et des
concepts utilisés et fondamental
nous devons nous les démocraties me
semble-t-il je parle en tant que citoyen
libre comparaissant devant un parlement
démocratiquement élu dans un pays libre
et la se mesure la chance que j'ai
le choix est ce que doivent faire les
démocraties c'est de continuer à se
battre pour leur propre valeur sur la
base de leur vocabulaire une agression
est une agression nous n'assistons pas
une guerre entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
nous assistons à la résistance d'un
peuple face à un voisin qu'il a envahi
ça devrait parler l'oreille et à l'oeil
d'un français ou d'une Française en tout
cas de ceux qui ont un certain âge me
semble-t-il alors comment s'y
prennent-ils pour affaiblir la
démocratie déjà en imposant leurs mots
et leur langage ce qui s'est traduit par
des recours d'abord
doux bénévolant
aux réseaux sociaux puisqu'il y a cette
extraordinaire paradoxe que les réseaux
sociaux qui sont par principe
des organes inventés pour la liberté
sont toujours mieux utilisés davantage
utilisé par les régimes autoritaires qui
veulent tuer la démocratie
le recours
aux médias et aux réseaux sociaux il y a
eu pendant que j'étais ambassadeur en
Russie des gens qui avaient été
volontaires entre guillemets pour
participer à des fermatrolles dans les
locaux du Kremlin ils avaient témoigné
publiquement en tout cas dans des médias
et dans des ONG qui avait encore un
petit peu le droit à la parole à
l'époque en disant clairement d'ailleurs
qu'ils étaient payés pour ce faire pour
relayer les positions du Kremlin je
rappelle que pendant toute la première
guerre du crâne j'étais ambassadeur à
Moscou il y avait tous les jours une
page envoyée par le porte-parole du
Kremlin ce pêche coffre
oui
à tous les médias russes sur ce qu'ils
avaient le droit de dire premièrement ce
qu'il n'avait pas le droit de dire
deuxièmement et troisièmement ce qu'il
devait dire et on a vu la création des
organes officiels comme Sputnik ou RT
qui sont aujourd'hui je crois interdits
dans toute l'Union européenne
aujourd'hui tout ça c'est sophistiqué
durci et on est passé des fermatrols à
la création de faux comptes à
l'utilisation de proxy à l'usurpation de
compte
si on pour objet très simple de propager
la vision et la propagande du Kremlin
mensonge y compris Joseph Staline je
crois et cité comme répétant que répéter
un mensonge finira par en faire une
vérité je pense que la filiation directe
entre Joseph Staline et Vladimir Poutine
fait qu'il a dû évidemment adopter cette
maxime alors je peux pas trop rentrer
dans le détail vous avez auditionné je
le sais je le crois Stéphane bouillon le
dial le secrétaire général le patron de
l'annecy et le patron de vigilance donc
une partie de ce que je sais vient
évidemment du fait
je le répète donc je suis membre du
Conseil éthique et scientifique qui suit
c'est le terme du décret je crois les
activités de vigilance je peux pas donc
rentrer dans le détail du fond des
actions de vigénome mais
ça ne fait aucun doute je crois que
feriol vous guérir vous a expliqué un
certain nombre d'opérations
de quoi s'agit-il il s'agit et c'est
important de décomposer peut-être
d'autres l'ont fait avant moins devant
vous il faut décrédibiliser la parole
d'abord des opposants russes donc des
canaux posant russe à la possibilité de
dire quelque chose je pense à navani par
exemple alors une certaine époque on les
assassinait
je pense à Anna Polito Scania je pense
évidemment à Boris niamsov assassiné
pendant mon séjour à Moscou à 150 mètres
du Kremlin sur un pont avec sa compagne
ukrainienne parce qu'il avait condamné
l'invasion de la Crimée en 2014 je pense
aux attentats à la sine je pense au SCRI
pas etc on va pas entrer dans le détail
mais enfin la liste est longue
je pense à l'excès une avalmie qui quand
même est rentré volontairement après
avoir été guéri par les Allemands après
une tentative d'assassinat par de la
scie par de par du poison et qui quand
même c'est un comble a été arrêté à
l'aéroport de Moscou pour avoir violé
les termes de sa résidence surveillée
pour aller se faire soigner pour pas
mourir
donc
pardon de rappeler ça mais voilà les
régimes dont on parle
et c'est bien de cela dont il faut se
défendre des gens qui sont capables de
faire ça sont capables de beaucoup de
choses donc décrédibiliser les opposants
en racontant des choses ignobles si
possible sur ce qu'ils font et notamment
je renvoie ceux qui ont un doute sur le
rôle important de naval ni à toutes les
vidéos que qu'il a publié avec son
organisation pour dénoncer notamment la
corruption au sein des élites en Russie
au sein des démocraties il s'agit de
quoi au fond tout simplement de
dévaloriser la parole publique
notamment des élus mais aussi des
scientifiques dans des tas de danse des
flots de propos inconsistants de noyer
leurs propos à travers des affirmations
contradictoires
d'insulter les personnes certains en ont
été la victime moi pas encore trop mais
après cette audition je m'attends à tout
là encore afin de décrédibiliser à
l'avance leurs parents et leurs actes et
j'insiste aujourd'hui sur un élément qui
me paraît important et notamment qu'on a
vu à l'oeuvre depuis la l'épidémie du
covid c'est la propagation par les
régimes autoritaires des tests
complotistes qu'elles soient d'ailleurs
américaines ou de l'extrême droite
américaine donc voilà n'importe qui ça
n'a aucune importance il s'agit pas
d'origine d'appellation contrôlées
appellation d'origine contrôlée de ce
point de vue là toutes les tests
complotistes sont les bonnes il s'agit
de faire douter tout le monde et de
créer cette espèce de café du commerce
planétaire au sein du quel se disent
sans doute les amis du Kremlin que il y
aura toujours quelqu'un pour dire c'est
pas vrai
en ne pouvant rien en ne démontrant rien
le combat des mots et des idées j'en ai
parlé il faut dévaloriser les mots alors
on parle de dont fait parler on parle de
dictature numérique de dictatures
sanitaire c'est extraordinaire j'ai
entendu des gens en France
dénoncer la dictature numérique et
sanitaire parce que il fallait
télécharger un QR code sur son téléphone
à l'époque du vide
quand on sait comment fonctionne la
Chine
avec le fameux crédit social avec 350
millions de caméras de reconnaissance
faciale il y en avait je crois qu'il y a
plus de 40 autour de l'ambassade le jour
où je suis parti j'ai fait le tour pour
les compter pour être sûr que toute
personne qui rentrait à l'Ambassade ou
chinois qui est en train à l'ambassade
était du monde documentée qui fait que
quand vous arrivez dans un commerce
en Chine vous avez sur l'ordinateur du
commerçant votre bobine passez-moi
l'expression et vos tenants et
aboutissants
le Crédit Social vous le savez c'est des
points qu'on perd on les a à la
naissance maintenant et on les perd et
on est sanctionné la sanction la plus
grave étant le renvoie dans votre
village autrement dit vous êtes finis
parce que c'est ça que ça veut dire en
Chine donc les mêmes certains que
j'entendais défendre le régime chinois
et l'agression insupportable d'un
certain nombre de pays qui mettaient en
cause le comportement chinois dans le
nom la non-information sur l'épidémie du
covid dénonçait la dictature numérique
en France voilà cette confusion des mots
cette dévalorisation des mots cette
contradiction
dans le soutien et le non soutien est
une tactique évidemment importante il
faut simplement semer la confusion et
tout ça notamment est utilisé pour
amplifier les crises démocratiques
au moment de la crise des gilets jaunes
alors là vous me pardonnerez j'ai un peu
oublié si j'étais en Russie ou en Chine
parce que les méthodes étaient tellement
les mêmes que je confusionne c'était
quand le la crise des gilets jaunes je
pense que j'étais ambassadeur en Chine
je ne me souviens plus très bien voilà
et donc il y a une photo extraordinaire
qui a fait la une du quotidien du peuple
et on voyait un truc qui explosait avec
des gens qui courraient derrière tout ce
qu'on est la moindre idée d'ailleurs de
savoir si c'était des victimes un peu de
Bengale un feu d'artifice un fumigène
une grenade lacrymogène ou quoi que ce
soit d'autre
et on disait voilà la situation en
France
mais évidemment il n'y avait aucun
commentaire sur le fait de savoir
pourquoi
des gens manifestaient avec des gilets
jaunes parce que vous imaginez bien que
le pouvoir chinois n'allait pas écrire
que c'était des gens qui manifestaient
contre leur propre gouvernement
fâcheuse idée
d'implanter
auprès des Chinois l'idée qu'on pouvait
se révolter dans une démocratie contre
son gouvernement voilà le genre de
contradiction aussi auxquelles il faut
faire attention mais la manipulation des
fêtes le brexit la crise des gilets
jaunes
il y a d'autres exemples où on a vu
déferler ça je pense que vigilino m'a dû
vous en parlait on a vu défaire les
tweets manifestement
fabriqués groupés télescopé lors de
crise comme évidemment
la pandémie du covid le soutien hôtesse
antivax des complotistes etc
ces manipulations de l'information
étrangère sont fréquentes mais là je
vous renvoie de nouveau une fois aux
déclarations qui a pu faire j'imagine
Stéphane bouillon et qu'on peut faire
Stéphane bouillon et Gabriel Ferriol les
exemples les plus connus c'est
évidemment l'intervention russe dans les
la campagne électorale américaine et
dans la campagne électorale française en
2017 12 pardon non 17 pardon
en attaquant des comptes et plus
intéressant
c'est pas si ça a été rendu public mais
en fabriquant des faux comptes du
président de la République alors ça on
le voit encore aujourd'hui tous les
jours donc ça c'est public et d'ailleurs
je crois que c'est l'exemple qui a été
donné par vigilum dans un reportage qui
a été fait sur la 5 je crois sur les
manipulations de l'information sur les
manipulations de l'information par la
Russie à l'initiative du groupe Wagner
de Monsieur Prigogine au Sahel et le
fameux faux charnier inventé filmé
diffuser par les Russes il y a eu un
reportage donc je crois que c'était sur
France 5
sur ce sujet donc c'est public
alors dernier élément qui me paraît
important et qui fait le lien entre
votre première question monsieur le
Président et la deuxième c'est
évidemment par ces régimes la
constitution de réseau d'amis
moi je les appelais les Français ourson
et les Français panda
j'ai déposé les mots
ça c'est évidemment aussi une pratique
bien établie moi je me souviens quand
j'étais étudiant j'avais été démarché
par un gars très sympathique dans un
café
du quartier latin et j'ai fini par me
rendre compte au bout de 5 minutes de
conversation que il travaillait pour
l'ambassade américaine et qui cherchait
à m'embarquer pour savoir ce qui se
passait dans les manifestations anti-vie
Vietnam à l'époque pardon je suis un peu
plus âgé que vous donc bien sûr ça c'est
fait de tout temps
de se constituer des réseaux d'amis
évidemment les États-Unis la Chine la
Russie mais aussi la Turquie l'Arabie
saoudite l'Iran tous les pays qui ont
des soit divisé hégémoniques soit des
difficultés sur la scène internationale
là la difficulté c'est de ne pas
confondre ceux qui se mêlent d'activité
de manipulation de l'information d'un
gérance et qui sont en fait des
cybercriminels
ce dont on a eu plusieurs exemples vous
le savez notamment
qui remonte qui permet de tracer la
source d'un certain nombre de
manipulations de l'information en Israël
qui est un pays connu pour ces startups
et sa tech et puis on a eu des exemples
très récents dans les médias qui
remontaient en Israël qui est parfois
d'ailleurs un intermédiaire j'ai vu le
cas quand j'étais en Chine
d'opération frauduleuse
faisant l'objet de recours de justice
qui transitait par Israël mais qui en
réalité venait de Chine donc mais ça
c'est de la cybercriminalité d'une
certaine façon ce qui nous intéresse ce
sont les États qui émettent les idées
qui sont propagées
et qui mettent en cause la cyber
sécurité j'aurais dû mentionner pardon
tout à l'heure les attaques durs comme
par exemple bien sûr toutes les
opérations de hacking je comprends que
l'Assemblée nationale a été elle-même
victime il y a quelques jours
des feux de service c'est le niveau 0,5
c'est le plus basique dans le dans le
le hacking d'un hôpital récemment je
crois que la Russie a été mise en cause
mais je l'ai lu dans la presse je ne
sais pas si c'est vrai ou pas donc
déstabiliser les institutions
démocratiques par le hacking ça c'est
évidemment alors là il y a pas beaucoup
d'États qui le font quand même parce que
si vous vous faites pincer c'est quand
même assez difficile à justifier mais la
difficulté face à toutes ces pratiques
c'est évidemment de savoir comment les
détecter comment les voir
comment les détecter et comment comment
réagir c'est souvent difficile à
détecter parce que en démocratie
nous sommes un état de droit c'est à la
justice de constaté qu'il y a une
violation du droit et pardon je vais
revenir à l'exemple que la question que
vous m'avez posée au tout début monsieur
le Président et j'ai presque fini je
vous assure moi je suis ambassadeur à
Moscou j'ai un doute sur ce que vient de
faire un syndrome de gens à Moscou je ne
constate aucun délit
je n'ai que des suspicions qui sont
liées à quoi à mon expérience à ma
connaissance comme j'ai eu des doutes
soyons clairs sur d'autres personnalités
d'autres bords quand j'étais en Chine
les groupes d'amitié servent hélas
parfois
au mieux à des voyages touristiques
soyons honnêtes j'en ai reçu beaucoup
parfois des voyages extrêmement sérieux
extrêmement important j'ai témoigné
devant beaucoup de commissions des
affaires de la commission des affaires
étrangères sur des sujets très précis et
les rapports parlementaires sont
extraordinairement importants mais
parfois ceux qui dirigent les groupes
d'amitié ont des intérêts
sur lesquels on peut se poser des
questions
si vous voulez que je donne un exemple
pour bien montrer que je ne m'attaque
pas qu'à la Russie je me nomme a déjà
attaque personne d'ailleurs mais je ne
parle pas que de la Russie c'est vrai
que je me suis posé des questions sur
les intérêts personnels ou public du
président du groupe d'amitié Francine à
une certaine époque
et puis on peut s'interroger tout
simplement sur les intérêts économiques
ou financiers légaux ou pas d'ailleurs
c'est ça qui est difficile tu as un
certain nombre d'anciens chefs
d'entreprise d'anciens ministres
d'anciens Premier ministre qui ont des
cabinets de conseils qui continuent à
perturbablement un signaler les contrats
avec des entreprises dans tout le monde
sait qu'elles sont liées aux intérêts
soit de l'État russe soit de l'État
chinois mais ça je veux dire un
ambassadeur vous pensez bien que malgré
tout ce qu'on pense de formidable des
ambassadeurs il n'est pas dans nos
capacités de de à part de dire que bon
et d'en parler avec eux d'ailleurs
moi je l'ai fait je vous dis franchement
avec quelqu'un par exemple dont je ne
doute absolument pas de la bonne foi qui
est l'ancien Premier Jean-Pierre
Raffarin quand il venait à Pékin moi
j'étais ambassé un Pékin j'avais de
longues conversations avec lui on
s'entendait très bien mais pas le même
JD moi je suis pas l'homme politique de
toute façon donc en tant que ambassadeur
je le recevais je travaille avec lui il
était envoyé spécial du ministre
étrangère pour la promotion des intérêts
français en Chine notamment des PME
c'est un travail extrêmement important
on travaillait très très bien là-dessus
mais on a eu des débats assez
pas violent parce que l'exemplaires
enfin c'est violent c'était très calme
mais assez ferme sur qu'est-ce que c'est
que la démocratie en Chine
moi j'ai vu débarquer à Pékin sans qu'il
m'est prévenu d'ailleurs ça ça vous
redit d'autres exemples toute une série
de gens qui ont été invités par le
président sidji ping il faut le faire un
congrès à organiser par le Parti
communiste chinois sur la démocratie
politique
et où j'ai vu descendre de l'avion d'Air
France des hommes et des femmes
politiques français si c'était bien
gardé de me prévenir pas de peau on
parle pas dans pas de chance pour eux
dans ce vol là il y avait un secrétaire
d'État que j'étais allé accueillir donc
c'était pas de chance j'ai je les ai vu
sortir de l'avion bien
c'est pas grave vous me direz enfin
aller à Pékin à l'invitation du Parti
communiste pour discuter de démocratie
politique il faut quand même avoir du
courage
et le soir même quand tu es distribué
sur les tables le petit livre le gros
livre blanc 800 pages
dépensé de sites de voir des hommes
politiques français le brandir
comme dans ma jeunesse certains
brandissaient le petit livre rouge du
président Mao qu'on allait chercher à
l'ambassade de Chine avenue bino à
Neuilly parce que c'était à Neuilly il
faut le faire quand même
voilà donc il y a de quoi avoir des
doutes tout ça c'est pour revenir
monsieur le Président sur l'idée que on
peut se former une idée on peut avoir
des doutes en même temps croire à la
bonne foi je crois pas une seconde que
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Raffarin soit
acheté par l'État chinois je crois qu'il
est convaincu à juste titre d'ailleurs
de l'importance de la coopération
bilatérale avec la Chine c'est dans les
méthodes et c'est dans la façon de faire
qu'on peut avoir un désaccord moi en
tant qu'ambassadeur je soutenais ces
visites je suis resté en très bon terme
avec lui d'ailleurs mais bon il m'invite
pas
aux réunions de sa fondation voilà c'est
clair que nous ne pensons pas la même
chose sur le régime chinois mais je ne
veux pas mettre en exergue quelqu'un en
particulier c'est simplement pour donner
des exemples et montrer la difficulté
voilà alors après il y en a un qui le
font beaucoup plus consciemment
je vais pas entrer dans le détail mais
pour ceux qui ont habité Moscou à
l'époque de la première guerre en
Ukraine le comportement de la Communauté
française
qui quand même venait défiler jusque
devant l'ambassade le 9 mai avec un
t-shirt rouge à l'effigie de Vladimir
Poutine
c'est difficile à accepter quand on est
ambassadeur de France vous n'avez pas
idée des termes qui ont été employés
dans les réunions où j'étais convoquée
pour justifier la politique française
et les sanctions prises contre la contre
la Russie à l'époque de l'annexion de la
Crimée les insultes que j'ai entendu
contre le président de la République
personnellement la prise à partie
d'homme politique qui était de passage
et qui essayait comme il pouvait de
donner leur avis personnel sur la
question j'ai été convoqué par le
célèbre observatoire franco-russe des
membrement de la Chambre de commerce
dont hélas le président qui est un homme
bien
a pris la nationalité russe après
l'invasion de l'Ukraine en février
dernier
oui il y a des relais d'influence y
compris français à Moscou comme à Paris
je vous parle pas du dialogue
franco-russe c'est connu ces documenté
ses publics
face à tout cela il faut réagir et je me
réjouis de ce point de vue là de la
création de votre commission je vous
remercie monsieur le président
merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur pour cette
exposé préliminaire et d'avoir répondu
effectivement à aux trois types de
questions dans mon Sauveur de ma part
dans la manière dont je voulais poser
parce que vous vouliez montrer afin que
vous vouliez nous rassurer sur le fait
que vous attaquez pas la Russie
justement dans il me semble dans mon
exposé préliminaire j'avais bien précisé
que vous aviez votre poste en Russie des
questions sur votre poste en Russie des
questions sur votre poste en Chine et en
troisième je vous ai bien je vous ai
spécifiquement demandé vous pouviez
élargir justement votre votre analyse à
votre expérience effectivement vous
l'avez dit de de haut fonctionnaires et
même de citoyens français la première
question monsieur Ripert ce sera je vous
demande évidemment pas de de cas
d'espèces qui se rencontradiction avec
les responsabilités que vous avez vu en
tant que ambassadeur mais dans la
manière générale
dont on travaille quand on est
ambassadeur diplomate et dont vous êtes
informés par les services ou par le Quai
d'Orsay ou par les différentes
institutions de l'État justement des
affaires des risques liés au risque
d'ingérence d'influ
de personnes qui pourraient avoir de
double allégeance voir d'ailleurs une
simple allégeance pour un État étranger
et puis du tout d'allégance pour leur
pays d'origine à savoir la France
autrement dit ma question c'est est-ce
qu'un ambassadeur en particulier dans
des pays aussi stratégiques et sensibles
évidemment que la Russie et la Chine en
particulier dans les périodes où vous
avez été en poste est-ce que une fois
plus évidemment de se créer ni de parler
de cas d'espèces mais dans la manière
générale dont cela fonctionne est-ce que
vous êtes informé par les services
idoine des cas compliqués est-ce que
vous avez des des services à votre
disposition en particulier dans des
ambassades aussi importantes qui vous
aident à identifier à comprendre ces
menaces vous êtes en lien avec des
spécialistes qui peuvent vous informer
vous et vos collaborateurs ce qui
travaille de manière temporaire enfin
passagère pardon ou plus permanente à
l'ambassade autrement dit est-ce que sur
place nos diplomates et les personnes
qui travaillent pour notre diplomatie
sont armés informés armés au sens
littéral du terme bien sûr on les moyens
les moyens humains matériels
intellectuels de prévenir de d'enseigner
sur le terrain ces risques d'ingérence
et les conséquences que ça pour notre
pays
merci monsieur le Président je pense que
c'est une question c'est une question
fondamentale
d'abord les ambassadeurs comme tous les
fonctionnaires comme tous les Français
d'ailleurs sont tenus de respecter les
lois et les règlements
donc évidemment pas de d'intrusion
possible dans la vie privée des gens et
notamment les consulats sont tenus à
toute une série de protection des
données personnelles qu'ils peuvent
recueillir parce que ils établissent des
documents d'identité parce qu'ils
établissent des listes électorales qui
ont le droit de donner à certains mais
pas à d'autres etc
deuxièmement évidemment l'essentiel du
travail d'un ambassadeur
de mon point de vue
il est dans le sens pays où il est
accrédité vers la France notre rôle
principal pour pouvoir mieux d'ailleurs
évidemment relayer les intérêts de la
France dans les pays où on est accrédité
c'est d'informer Paris pour faire court
le mieux possible
d'informations brute
d'analyse et de proposition
d'informations brute en réalité assez
peu parce que moi je l'ai souvent répété
à mes collaborateurs les ambassades
c'est pas l'AFP on n'est pas aujourd'hui
les médias et les réseaux sociaux font
beaucoup plus rapide que c'est plus
rapide que d'envoyer un télégramme
encore que maintenant on a des méthodes
de communication instantanée y compris
dans l'administration mais enfin bon
c'est surtout l'analyse c'est la
contextualisation de ce qu'on voit qui
est le plus important et évidemment pour
Paris ce qui m'a toujours semblé évident
c'est que c'est la contextualisation de
ce qui se passait pour reprendre les
exemples puisque c'est là que j'ai pas
été ambassé aux États-Unis donc je peux
pas parler là de j'étais en société mais
il y a très longtemps
de la Russie de ce qui se passe parmi
les décideurs pour faire court dans tous
les secteurs il y a pas que la politique
il y avait aussi l'économie bien sûr
fondamentale pour défendre les intérêts
de nos entreprises et l'État français
dans les négociations internationales
mais donc
décrypter analyser le fonctionnement le
mode mode de prise de décision le type
de publicité faite aux décisions et ça
c'était
essentiellement
c'était particulièrement difficile
pardon comme vous l'avez souligné en
Russie et en Chine d'abord parce que la
presse n'est pas libre
ensuite donc ce documenté de source
ouverte est compliquée
c'était encore possible en Russie parce
que la Russie malgré ses efforts n'a
jamais réussi à copier le grand mur de
great fire chinois donc contrôler mal
son internet contrairement à la Chine
qui la contrôle pas complètement c'est
impossible mais qui la contrôle bien
très vite mais qui ne peut pas le
contrôler complètement d'ailleurs mais
enfin bon alors en Chine on avait une
méthode de travail extrêmement
intéressante qui était de comparer les
mêmes articles paru dans la presse
chinoise pour les Chinois et la presse
chinoise pour les étrangers et comme on
a d'excellence sinophones spécialiste de
la Chine ok c'était pareil en Russie
c'est souvent très intéressant de
comparer ne serait-ce que les mots que
vous le savez en chinois les mots enfin
je sais pas je parle pas chinois je
parle baragouiner un peu le pénible mais
pas le chinois mais c'est intéressant
parce que ça permet de voir non
seulement ce que les Chinois eux savent
le peuple chinois mais aussi la façon
dont les autorités chinoises veulent que
le message passe à l'étranger puisque il
y a toujours ce double rôle donc ça
c'était une façon de travailler en
Russie impossible quasiment en Chine de
de d'avoir des conversations privées
d'ordre politique ou autre sauf bien sûr
ça arrange on se fait les amis on
construit son réseau on rencontre des
gens le soir au fond d'un bois enfin bon
on a tous fait ça au fond d'un café
enfin c'est un peu difficile il faut
être honnête
et puis on décrypte quand même on
apprend et c'est ça la spécificité du
métier de diplomate j'en profite pour je
sais qu'il y a une commission qui a
travaillé sur le métier de diplomate
c'est à ça qui servent les diplomates
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont utiles c'est
que quand ils ont 30 ans ou 40 ans de
métier comme j'avais en arrivant en
Chine on sait décrypter le comportement
d'un diplomate chinois
vous pensez mieux que d'autres disons
voilà bon bref pardon pour cette défense
illustration des diplomates mais il y
aurait pas de diplomatie sans diplomate
à mon avis mais donc le retour c'est
tenter bien sûr d'influer sur la
décision prise à Paris à Paris parce que
moi j'ai jamais fait partie des
ambassadeurs qui attendaient benoîtement
qu'on l'a envoyé des instructions moi je
disais voilà ce que je pense et donc
voilà ce que j'aimerais recevoir comme
instruction parce que c'est ça que je
pense qu'il faut faire alors Paris
disait oui Paris disait non pari couper
la poire en deux puis on applique les
instructions quand on est ambassadeurs
je n'ai jamais eu de problème éthique
sinon je j'aurais évidemment
démissionner si j'avais eu un problème
fondamental mais
cette information
c'est tout l'art du diplomate on
s'appuie sur un réseau de remarquable
spécialiste en Russie et en Chine en
tout cas moi j'ai eu la chance de
bénéficier notamment d'agents qui
travaillaient sur la politique
intérieure travailler au service de
presse au service culturel qui permet
d'en apprendre beaucoup quand vous
recevez des Russes à l'Institut français
ou à l'Alliance française ou en Chine
vous laissez traîner vos oreilles et
puis vous avez des débats pas sur des
sujets politiques mais sur des sujets de
société ça permet de comprendre beaucoup
de choses donc on s'informe mutuellement
mais et là je ne veux pas entrer dans le
détail parce que vous savez bien que
la base de la théorie française en
matière de lutte contre pour la sécu de
manière générale en matière de défense
de sécurité de lutte contre la
cybercriminalité la cyber sécurité et
pour la cybersécurité c'est qu'on
informe pas l'adversaire de ce qu'on
sait sinon on lui donne les moyens de
résister mais globalement
je pense que la France à l'étranger est
victime comme la France de France ménage
par latine citoyen
de grandes difficultés encore dans la
coopération inter-administrative pour
être pudique
vous allez dans une réunion au
Département des temps et moi j'ai
participé quand j'étais premier
secrétaire à l'ambassade à Washington a
des réunions à l'époque c'était sur la
guerre au Tchad ou la guerre en
Afghanistan je me souviens plus très
bien j'étais invité à des réunions et il
y avait autour de la table tout le monde
y compris la CIA
parce que le département d'État un rôle
naturel de coordination de tout ce qui
touche à l'internation et je vous dis
pas que le gars de la CIA a raconté tout
mais en tout cas il était là
pas le souvenir d'avoir participé à
beaucoup de réunions qu'elle leur sait
on a invité la DGSE ça a peut-être
changé moi j'ai quitté la maison il y a
trois ans et j'ai quitté Paris il y a 18
ans maintenant parce que j'ai servi 15
ans continuant à l'étranger donc je ne
prétends pas connaître comment
fonctionne au jour le jour depuis 18 ans
le Quai d'Orsay mais en fin de ce que
j'en ai vu je pense qu'on a un problème
et que dans la situation actuelle où
nous sommes et dans la lutte contre les
ingérences et les influences il me
paraît clair qu'un degré supplémentaire
ou supérieur de coordination et
coopération interagir
ne ferait pas de mal et quand je dis
interagit c'est bien sûr la DGSE la DGSI
le quai d'Orsel ministère de la Défense
enfin tous ceux qui ont en connaître
l'annecy pardon vigilum et tous ceux qui
ont à connaître
l'arcome pour les médias etc parce que
la détection des attaques d'où qu'elles
viennent ou des tentatives d'attaque ou
des manipulations elle se fait souvent
par l'observation collective de
phénomènes dont plusieurs ont simplement
une vue parcellaire vous notez quelque
chose qui vous paraît bizarre pourquoi
un tel a-t-il rencontré une telle et
c'est parce que quelqu'un d'autre sait
qu'il y ait une telle ou c'est qui est
un tel que vous arrivez bon bref donc
cet aspect là est difficile les
ambassadeurs il s'agit pas de pleurer
sur les ambassadeurs mais nous n'avons
accès
en source non ouverte nous avons accès
essentiellement aux informations qui
nous viennent de notre maison du
ministère faire étrangères
bien sûr du ministère de l'intérieur
quand il s'agit de pratique consulaire
c'est pas neutre un je mentionne le
consulat parce que notamment quand on
établit des sanctions
ça veut dire qu'il y a un problème il
faut bloquer les visas donc c'est
important que de s'assurer que les là il
n'y a pas vraiment de problème de
coordination notamment parce que les
consuls généraux sont encore très
largement originaires du Quai d'Orsay
avec le ministère de la Défense il y a
des attachés de défense on ne partage
pas tout bien qu'on soit accrédité quand
on est ambassadeur à un très haut niveau
d'accès
on a une habilitation très haut niveau
je vais pas entrer dans le détail donc
on a le droit de lire un centre de
documents on ne les a pas forcément très
souvent
en même temps alors phénomène bien connu
on a accès à un certain nombre de notes
très utiles établies par les services
sauf en ce qui concerne en général le P
où vous travaillez ce qui fait que ce
n'est pas très très commode
donc beaucoup dépendent votre relation
avec
votre
représentant local public c'est il y a
des représentants locaux officiels
donc je ne travaillais aucun secret en
disant ce que je viens de dire
parce qu'il coopèrent parce que par
exemple on coopère avec la Russie et la
Chine dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
même pendant la guerre en Ukraine on a
continué à travailler avec les Russes
sur la lutte contre le terrorisme
islamique parce que hélas s'ils ont été
eux aussi extrêmement touchés par le
terrorisme islamique avec la Chine c'est
plus compliqué parce que comme pour les
terroristes c'est les Ouigours plus
difficile de coopérer avec eux enfin bon
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
donc on a en général des services
officiels qui travaillent avec les pays
avec
auprès des pays serait plus correct de
dire et on se parle et il y a moi je
n'ai jamais eu de problème particulier
je n'ai jamais eu de défauts
d'information en même temps sur le
président quand on ne vous donne pas une
information vous ne savez pas qu'elle
existe
c'est une évidence mais qu'il faut
rappeler nous savons ce que nous savons
le fait que nous ne sachions pas quelque
chose ne veut pas dire que ce quelque
chose n'existe pas on ne sait pas
produit mais je pense que là il y a
certainement quelque chose à renforcer
dans le respect de la loi parce que
évidemment tous les services de l'État
qui doivent appliquer la loi bien
entendu et notamment ce qui concerne la
protection des données personnelles le
respect des procédures ont parfois des
contraintes ou des modes de réglement
particulier qui font que ils ne peuvent
pas coopérer pleinement les uns avec les
autres pardon de la longueur de ma
réponse
non non mais vous en prie mais je pense
que là
l'ampleur de ma question votre réponse
convenait parfaitement j'ai pas eu tout
l'impression qu'il y a eu de redit sauf
erreur de ma part j'ai noté le mot que
vous avez été convoqué par
l'Observatoire des relations
francophones non mais c'est le j'essaie
d'exercer depuis la Commission et une
présidence aussi qui est vu la
sensibilité du sujet qui permet de
sortir des auditions sans ambiguïté et
que chacun précise les mots parce que
les mots ont un sens pour ceux qui nous
écoutent pour ceux la presse qui
travaille pour ceux qui vont faire pour
madame le rapporteur qui va avoir un
gros travail donc moi mon but c'est
juste que c'est juste que les bons mots
soient c'est tout ça date pas une robe à
reproche j'ai noté peut corriger
j'ai noté mais même d'ailleurs au-delà
du mot est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliciter cet épisode c'est ça ma
question c'est pas juste pour savoir le
mot donc j'avais noté ce mot donc pour
savoir si ce mot correspond à une
réalité que vous voulez décrire ou si ça
peut arriver à n'importe qui c'est pas
du tout une critique c'est pas vraiment
ce que vous voulez dire et si vous
pouviez nous expliciter cet épisode
puisqu'effectivement l'Observatoire des
relations franco-russes et c'est comme
ça que c'est bien le bon terme
vous pouvez nous expliquer cet épisode
et en tant qu'ambassadeur votre regard
sur cette organisme s'il vous plaît oui
pardon quand j'ai dit convocation
c'était une image non pas autorité sur
moi ils ne peuvent pas me convoquer la
convoquer au sens où on a exercé sur moi
d'amical pression qui ont été tellement
fortes que j'ai fini par accepter
d'aller leur parler voilà bon je n'ai
pas été convoqué mais le bocon vocation
un sens
je dirais pour être plus proche de la
réalité que j'ai eu le sentiment de
comparaître
devant l'Observatoire
il faut se replacer à l'époque de la
première guerre du crâne et l'invasion
et l'annexion illégale de la Crimée et
de Sébastopol
annexé illégalement quelques mois plus
tard officiellement et le déclenchement
d'une guerre civile au Dombas par des
milices mafieuses
tout ça et documenté
financé armé par Moscou
contrairement à ce que les Russes
croyaient probablement à l'époque
l'Union européenne a tout de suite réagi
et a décidé de sanction
ça me permet de revenir d'ailleurs à la
question précédente d'une certaine façon
nous avons fait partie à l'ambassade
évidemment
du réseau des ambassadeurs européennes
qui ont alimenté nos capitales
quand il a fallu établir la liste des
sanctions notamment contre les entités
les individus
les responsables politiques
ou économiques ou ce que vous voudrez
français allemand belge etc avec des
idées
mais évidemment ils nous ont consulté
notamment pour savoir qui est qui
tel pays a suggéré qu'on mette sur la
liste des sanctionnés monsieur X qu'en
pensez-vous qui est-ce nous ne savons
pas qui c'est parce que chaque pays a un
peu ses réseaux entre guillemets
moi je travaillais que le président du
groupe d'amitié franco-rus le célèbre
monsieur slowski grand ami de la France
m'avait-on expliqué du côté des amis de
la Russie entre guillemets avant que je
parte qui aujourd'hui a été élu enfin il
y a quelques semaines a été élu le
président du parti
extrémiste raciste homophobe
nationaliste LDPR
pour succéder au célèbre monsieur
jérinoski
bon moi je travaillais avec lui enfin je
travaillais j'ai parlé du président du
groupe d'amitié donc il invitait des
députés français
aux demandes un homme en privé
parfaitement aimable
l'allemand il travaillait avec le
président du groupe d'amitié boule de
stagne voilà bon donc on échangeait un
peu pour essayer de savoir
qui était ces gens et surtout parce que
c'est ça qui était pertinent est-ce
qu'ils avaient d'une manière ou d'une
autre
participer contribuer ou soutenu
l'annexion de la Crimée
la notion illégale de la Crimée
et je précise tout de suite en ce qui me
concerne que pour moi la question n'est
pas de savoir si l'imprimer est
historiquement russe ou ukrainienne je
n'en sais rien je ne suis pas historien
la question est d'accepter ou pas qu'un
pays puisse occuper militairement et
annexer un territoire voisin c'est
étonnant de cela que l'Union européenne
a condamné l'annexion c'est pas en
disant
l'Ukraine et russe historiquement et
culturellement c'est en disant l'UK la
Crimée est ukrainienne juridiquement
parce qu'elle fait partie de l'État dont
on a reconnu les frontières
internationales conformément la Charte
des Nations Unies
mais surtout ce que nous condamnons
c'est le mode d'annexion évidemment
parce que c'est ce qui s'est produit
quelquefois dans l'histoire de notre
continent on en a pas vraiment gardé des
bons souvenirs donc le problème n'était
pas celui-là le problème est juridique
pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce que
donc il fallait trouver des gens
au regard de ce critère l'un donc moi
j'estimais qu'on avait pas sanctionné
quelqu'un qui me disait un soir dans un
dîner évidemment que la Crimée est russe
on a le droit de penser ça c'est une
erreur pour moi mais on a le droit de le
penser en revanche quelqu'un qui a
milité pour l'annexion qui a justifié
l'annexion
a priori ou a postériori celui-là a pris
position c'est le cas notamment de
Monsieur souscrit ça a été le cas
d'ailleurs d'un certain nombre d'hommes
et de femmes politiques français ou
européen donc c'est là-dessus qu'il faut
porter un jugement de mon point de vue
pas sur ce qu'il pense sur le fait qu'il
valide juridiquement une agression
militaire c'est ça que c'était en cause
bref il fallait donc trouver
appliquer ces critères et donc là
évidemment
les ambassades ont été appelés à l'aide
et clairement je ne travaille pas de
secret en disant que c'est pas moi tout
seul dans mon bureau qui faisait des
listes évidemment je consultais
les personnes qui s'occupaient du
secteur de la presse du secteur
économique et qui connaissait les
entreprises je consultais le conseiller
économique je consultais l'attacher de
défense je consultais le représentant
des services pour essayer d'en savoir
plus sur monsieur X ou Madame Y
parce que en plus moi j'étais pas là
depuis très longtemps je vous rappelle
que moi je suis arrivé à Moscou le 2
novembre 2013 et que la Grima était
envahi en février 2014 donc je peux pas
vous dire que je connaissais le bottin
administratif russe par coeur ça c'est
bon donc là il y a eu quand même sa
réponse aussi un petit peu à la question
d'avant là évidemment il y avait une
coopération localement de tous les
membres de l'ambassade et quand on a
envoyé notre avis à Paris il y avait une
concertation donc on informe mais on
informe aussi pour pouvoir définir ce
que Paris doit faire
doit proposer comme donner comme
instruction pour pouvoir agir en défense
des intérêts de la France c'est dans ce
double sens que ça se passe est-ce que
j'ai répondu à la question sur la
convocation oui si pardon alors donc
dans ce contexte là
j'ai immédiatement proposé à la
Communauté française donc assez
représentants notamment les élus
consulaires puisque vous savez que les
élus consulaires dans les
circonscriptions
à ce députés à l'époque il y avait pas
de sénateur mais il y avait un député
représentant représente représentant la
circonscription consulaire électorale à
l'Assemblée nationale comme vous le
savez Thierry Mariani n'était pas là
très souvent mais quand il était là on
se voyait on se parlait et enfin il ne
venait pas des réunions que j'organisais
moins avec la Communauté française
c'était pas à sa place et d'ailleurs il
n'a jamais demandé mais je lui ai
toujours proposé d'y participer mais
donc je réunissais et j'ai réuni
quasiment toutes les semaines pendant
des mois
avec notamment le conseiller commercial
le président de la Chambre de commerce
le président
du de la des conseillers du commerce
extérieur et une
[Musique]
un certain nombre de
représentants des intérêts économiques
français
représentatif petit et moyenne
entreprise Industrie Services
technologies agriculture choisie par la
Chambre de commerce
et son président et pendant
des semaines
j'ai essayé de leur expliquer
j'ai essayé de leur expliquer pourquoi
le gouvernement faisait ce qu'il faisait
pourquoi l'Europe faisait ce qu'elle
faisait je les écoutais m'expliquer
l'impact des sanctions puisque vous
savez qu'après les sanctions européennes
il y a eu des contre-sensions Russes qui
avaient un impact bien entendu sur les
entreprises françaises notamment dans le
dans l'agriculture et on essayait de
voir ensemble
comment
minimiser cet impact et pas de
contradiction en tant qu'ambassadeur je
devais à la fois défendre la politique
gouvernementale européenne de sanctions
et en même temps aider nos entreprises à
essayer de s'en sortir
dans cette situation
ces réunions étaient très difficiles
très très difficile certains perdaient
leur nerfs
et il y avait des campagnes dans la dans
la feuille de choux local française dans
vous savez c'est un petit monde les
communautés étrangères à l'étranger pas
à l'époque à Moscou il doit y avoir 6000
personnes ou quelque chose comme ça tout
le monde se connaît donc c'est très bien
dans quel café les gens disent où est-ce
qu'ils se retrouvent on les écoute
parler et puis vous avez toujours des
oreilles de charitable et des gens qui
viennent vous raconter ce qui se passe
donc tout le monde sait tout sur tout le
monde en réalité c'est clochemar très
souvent pardon de le dire mais c'est la
réalité tous ceux qui ont fréquenté des
communautés françaises le savent en tout
cas ceux qui sont actifs c'est un petit
groupe c'est normal bien donc on sentait
l'attention monter j'entendais des
choses quand même encore une fois qui
moi mon profondément choqué comme
contestation par des français de la
démocratie
de la France
de leurs autorités de leurs institutions
pourquoi par idéologie par conviction
par intérêt personnel
tout simplement par j'ai envie de dire
le mot syndrome de Stockholm mais est
inapproprié en l'espèce parce qu'ils
sont pas retenus en otage mais mais
l'amour qu'on finit par ressentir pour
le pays on a décidé de faire sa vie
c'est parfaitement compréhensible mais
je leur disais toujours vous êtes
français quand vous rentrez en France
c'est pas parce que vous aimez la France
que vous ne vous privez de critiquer vos
hommes politiques y compris votre
président
est-ce que ça ne devrait pas être vrai
dans l'autre sens donc il y avait
beaucoup d'agressivité
j'ai fini par penser que
qu'il fallait que je réponde
positivement
la demande de l'Observatoire au nom de
la Chambre de commerce de m'écouter sur
cette rationalité et surtout en réalité
d'écouter mes questions et tenter d'y
répondre parce que ce qu'il voulait
c'était me faire passer leur message à
eux donc voilà pourquoi j'ai dit
convoquer c'était un mot inapproprié
bien sûr j'ai accepté d'être auditionné
par eux d'ailleurs ils avaient fait une
captation vidéo je possède existe encore
mais c'était dans un climat extrêmement
hostile et défavorable
[Musique]
à la France à ces autorités à ses
institutions que j'ai téléchargé de
défendre en temps et que je représente
d'abord parce que ce qu'on oublie trop
souvent c'est qu'un ambassadeur il
représente pas son pays comme vous le
savez il représente personnellement le
chef de l'État il représente les
intérêts de son pays mais vraiment de ce
chef de l'État donc quand quelqu'un
insulte le chef de l'État l'ambassadeur
doit réagir
voilà bon voilà pourquoi le contexte
était très tendu
mais on a tenu bon et on s'est parlé on
a continué à se parler pendant des mois
et des mois mais c'était difficile
[Musique]
je crois pas que le globe morue c'est
besoin
de tel ou telle chef de PME française en
Russie pour faire passer les messages
quand vous êtes un chef de PME le chef
d'une PME étrangère en Russie de toute
façon excusez-moi vous êtes vous
obéissez
parce que ce ne sont pas des états de
droit
ce ne sont pas des états on respecte la
propolisé intellectuelle
oui oui non mais privé ou public enfin
je veux dire vous avez raison prix
personnel ou d'entreprises donc
globalement les chefs d'entreprise ils
faisaient ce qu'ils pouvaient pour voilà
donc de fait
j'en ai connu assez peu qui prenaient la
parole ouvertement
contre le régime russe
donc de ce point de vue là il y avait
pression mais pas particulière on peut
pas le dire
il y a des gens qui sont sensibles aux
honneurs
beaucoup de visiteurs en Russie ou en
Chine étaient très sensible au fait
qu'on leur payait des billets d'avion
alors quand c'est pour la Chine c'est
loin donc c'était dans des classes
[Musique]
élevés qu'on les reçoit dans des hôtels
très très chics tout frais payés qu'on
les promène qu'on leur donne une voiture
beaucoup de gens ils sont sensibles
je regrette vous dire et là ce que la
vanité humaine s'exerce partout
et je pense qu'il faut pas sous-estimer
cela
quand on parle des réseaux d'influence
sont pas forcément détruants sont pas
forcément des gens qui veulent nuire à
la France ils sont juste
peut-être naïf je sais pas ou trop
sensible à ces honneurs en se disant
mais des gens qui me traitent comme ça
peuvent pas être mauvais
voilà bon il y a ça deuxièmement il faut
pas oublier et ça je crois que c'est
vraiment important parce que il faut que
je défende maintenant les communautés
françaises beaucoup de Français
s'expatrient par choix parce qu'ils
aiment un pays parce qu'ils aiment un
homme ou une femme
ou pour créer une entreprise et qui
pense que les opportunités sont
meilleures ici ou là par exemple dans la
tech en Chine
ou dans l'agriculture en Russie qui
souffrait d'un
comme la Chine d'ailleurs d'un
déséquilibre intérieur en matière
alimentaire dans certaines catégories
mais quand vous êtes un patron
d'entreprise enfin faut pas mettre en
cause les entreprises bref quand vous
êtes un français qui a des intérêts
économiques légitimes en droit dans un
pays
et que vous êtes actif dans la chambre
de commerce dans le réseau des conseils
du commerce extérieur que vous êtes
reçus à dîner par l'ambassadeur parce
que faut pas se faire d'illusions Moscou
c'est Matin Midi et Soir ces petits
déjeuners de travail déjeuner de travail
dîner de travail parfois un cocktail et
parfois des des conférences le soir donc
vous envoyez passer du monde à votre
table d'ailleurs on vous le demande
c'est fait pour ça bien et puis c'est
surtout fait pour avoir moitié de rue ou
moitié de chinois ou moitié de Paul de
Valak et puis moitié de français donc
vous les voyez
vous avez en réalité à qui au fil des
années
un statut
vous êtes quelqu'un pardon de le dire en
toute naïveté vous êtes quelqu'un
si à cause des sanctions votre
entreprise périclite ou que votre siège
social décide de fermer et de vous
rapatrier vous étiez le patron d'une
grande de la branche russe d'une grande
entreprise française et on vous dit bon
bah désolé on ferme t'inquiète pas on
apporte tout un poste de directeur
technique à Vaulx-en-Velin
c'est dur
donc je pense et là je parle vraiment à
titre personnel et très librement il
faut comprendre aussi ça cette
difficulté là
qui fait que spontanément un certain
nombre de gens
écoutent peut-être d'une oreille un peu
trop positive
ce qu'on leur dit ou ce qu'ils entendent
ou ce qu'ils veulent l'entendre
idéalisent en quelque sorte le régime
vous êtes et puis quand vous êtes un
Français à Moscou soyons clairs
vous ne souffrez pas
de la plupart des restrictions aux
libertés qui sont imposées par le régime
de Vladimir Poutine à sa population
vous en tirez même quelques avantages
les syndicats sont pas vraiment remuant
il y a pas beaucoup de manifestations
on peut se promener à 11h du soir burger
qui parc m'a dit une Française
pour m'expliquer que c'était mieux qu'à
Paris ça c'est sûr qu'entre bois de
Boulogne et le corps qui parc l'ordre ne
règne pas de la même façon il y a des
gens qui sont sensibles c'est comme ça
bon ça c'est la première catégorie je
dirais c'est le citoyen français
expatrié il faut comprendre aussi la
difficulté dans laquelle parfois
l'expatriation vous place et puis il y a
les responsables
quand monsieur Mariani ou d'autres
vont constater entre guillemets le
caractère libre des élections en Crimée
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
on peut supposer quelqu'un lui a demandé
ce qui est pas sûr d'ailleurs puisqu'on
a vu aller en Syrie si je me souviens
bien dans des conditions qui étaient
plutôt pires il a peut-être fait de son
propre chef mais en tout cas on a compté
un certain nombre de délégations qui
sont allés en randonnions expliquer que
la Crimée terrus et justifier le
référendum
je rappelle quand même sauf erreur
faudrait vérifier les chiffres qui
avaient des élections municipales à
Sébastopol quelques semaines ou quelques
mois avant
l'annexion de la Crimée et que je crois
que le parti du maire de du futur perte
Sébastopol le parti prorus avait fait 4%
faudrait vérifier les chiffres mais en
tout cas il n'avait pas fait la majorité
contrairement à ce que beaucoup ont
raconté après donc les gens les hommes
politiques ou les femmes politiques qui
vont à Damas en pleine guerre en plein
bombardement chimique en Crimée en
pleine procédure d'addiction d'annexion
où se promener en Chine en plein drame
ouigo enfin pas en Chine vont faire un
sérum de déclaration en Chine en plein
drame ouigo cela on peut quand même
s'interroger sur les pressions qui
soient à la dépression qu'elle soit
amicales ou pas parce que vous dites
pression mais ça peut être des
incitations amicales
pas toujours parler de la même chose
mais
on a vu sur Canal+ je crois des extraits
de propos tenus par des députés russes
sur le fait qu'il fallait rendre
l'appareil
aux hommes et femmes politiques qui
étaient venus prêter main fortes sur la
légitimation de l'annexion de la Crimée
donc là on a plus de doute mais sans
encore une fois en tant qu'ambassadeur
moi quand quelqu'un se rendait en Crimée
moi j'avais rappelé à la Communauté
française que les décisions de l'Union
européenne c'est qu'on ne devait était
interdite toute échange je crois
investissement en Crimée ce qui
d'ailleurs n'a pas été sans difficulté
parce que dans mon souvenir il y a un
Français qui était Astérix mais à
l'envers a refusé de partir
je crois qu'il était dans le secteur du
tourisme j'ai un peu oublié pour être
honnête avec vous parce qu'il y a pas de
moyens de contraindre un Français qui
habite à l'étranger il fait ce qu'il
veut mais c'était je crois interdit par
par l'Union européenne
mais de ce point de vue là d'ailleurs
pardon sur les pressions
si on n'est pas omnubilé uniquement par
la Russie on pourrait parler de l'impact
et des pressions que représentent les
sanctions internationales
unilatérale imposée par exemple par les
États-Unis d'Amérique avec un caractère
extraterritorial
quand vous dites
c'est pas comparable mais c'est une
forme en termes de droit international
tout aussi critiquable d'ailleurs
l'Union européenne est vend debout et
comme vous le savez réfléchi à des
modalités pour essayer de se doter non
pas du même instrument parce que nous
considérons que cette illégal mais
d'instruments de qui lui permettent de
réagir à ce genre de choses quand vous
dites toute personne qui libérera un
contrat en dollars
avec Gazprom ou avec je sais pas qui
sera passible de peine de prison en
Russie pardon aux États-Unis
c'est une sacrée forme de pression et
d'ingérence
d'ingérence au sens où on interfère avec
la légalité de l'état où cela s'applique
pour la Chine on l'a vu avec
on a vu la double ingérence dans les
deux sens avec le cas de Madame Ming
vous savez
la directrice financière de Huawei la
fille du fondateur qui a été arrêté au
Canada parce que les États-Unis avaient
demandé son extradition et que comme les
Canadiens ont un traité d'extradition
avec les États-Unis ils avaient pas le
choix juridiquement
ce qui était reproché à Madame Mingue
c'était d'avoir
signé des contrats
occulte ou en tout cas sous des prêtres
non divers mais facilement identifiables
avec l'Iran et avec des pays qui
faisaient commerces avec les rangs
ingérence typique vous pourriez
qualifier ça d'un gérance au sens où on
demandait aux Chinois un certain les
Américains demandent chinoises en forme
de choses et en tout cas se permettait
de juger un citoyen chinois n'ayant pas
commis de crimes aux États-Unis sauf
qu'aux États-Unis c'est considéré comme
un crime de violer cette législation oui
dans quoi comme vous le savez les
Chinois n'ont fait ni une ni deux ils
ont arrêté les deux premiers Canadiens
qui tombent et qui descendaient d'un
avion et les ont gardé pendant trois ans
dans une cellule éclairée éclairée 24
heures sur 24 au seul en béton avec
visite consulaire une fois par mois
ça c'est le droit chinois au
caractéristiques chinoise c'est légal en
Chine
voilà donc c'est des formes de pression
mais ça veut dire quand même dire qu'un
séome de loin d'applications
extraterritoriale sont des peuvent
exercer des formes de pression mais le
plus souvent dans la formation des
réseaux à l'étranger on utilise les amis
du pays encore une fois les Français
oursons les Français panda ceux qui ont
des convictions ou des intérêts
personnels ou des intérêts d'entreprises
on utilise aussi bien sûr les
communautés étrangères c'est quelque
chose qu'il ne faut pas oublier qui est
extrêmement important
notamment quand on parle des Chinois
quelqu'un je ne sais plus quel organe de
près ça révélé récemment que l'Allemagne
avait accepté l'ouverture d'un bureau
officiel de la police chinoise ce que
nous nous avons toujours refusé
mais comme vous savez nous avons la
chance d'accueillir dans la région des
Trois Frontières
dans le nord-est à la fois la plus
grande communauté ouigo d'Europe et le
Congrès mondial ouigo et également je
crois le Congrès mondial kurde où je ne
sais plus comment ça s'appelle et donc
là il y a tout un paquet de Turcs et de
chinois qui se promènent dans ces villes
qui repère les gens qui les filme et qui
ensuite évidemment font pression sur eux
pour leur faire quitter le territoire
français alors qu'ils y sont les GO bien
entendu s'ils sont pas légaux je
n'évoque pas leur cam et des gens Lego
notamment des familles
il faut que tu rentres parce que sinon
tu sais ton papa qui habite dans tel
village au cynthiang on m'a dit qu'il
était pas en bonne santé
là je vous raconte des choses
documentées
pas à moi de donner mes sources
évidemment c'est parce que c'était dans
l'exercice de mes fonctions mais nous le
savons
le coup classique les faire rentrer pour
pouvoir ensuite les incarcérer
et vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé avec
l'autre main
le président chinois d'Interpol
arrêté à sa descente d'avion
lors de son départ en congé
il était encore vice-ministre en
exercice qui était d'ailleurs assez
curieux parce qu'il était publique en
Chine et en même temps présentateur Paul
enfin bon il s'est fait arrêter
par les autorités chinoises et ensuite
on a fait l'objet de pression terrible
pour livrer sa femme qui était restée
quelques jours en arrière un lion pour
s'organiser puisqu'ils habitaient Lyon
puisque c'est le siège d'Interpol donc
là il y a eu de la gérance croyez moi au
sens de la pression et si vous allez sur
les réseaux sociaux de l'époque vous
verrez tout ce qu'on racontait sur elle
sur lui enfin toutes ces choses qui
évidemment étaient d'origine chinoise
qui visait à créer y compris
probablement dans la communauté chinoise
française la Communauté française
d'origine chinoise un sentiment de
malaise ou de peur
parce que il y a aussi ça dans les
manipulations il y a l'idée de faire
peur aux communautés à l'étranger en
carade faire peur aux populations
d'origine kurde ou qui soit en Allemagne
en Suède ou
en France les ouigo pour les Chinois etc
etc donc
les tchétchène les tchétchchan j'aurais
dû citer les tchétchen plutôt que les
Kurdes parce que les Kurdes y sont
plutôt en Allemagne et en Suède mais les
tchétchène nous avons une très grosse
communauté de tchétchène dans l'Est de
la France c'est là aussi il y a des
ingérences évidentes des services russes
pour les faire taire et pour obtenir
soit qui rentre soit en tout cas les
merci Monsieur ambassade dernière
question avant de passer la parole à
Madame la rapporteur puis de au
commissaire c'est sur l'épisode LCI
même si vous l'aurez noté j'ai pas voulu
je ne veux jamais voulu réduire votre
expérience cette anecdote mais pour bien
comprendre une fois de plus si j'ai bien
compris les déclarations les précisions
que vous avez apportées ce jour mais si
c'est mal compris c'est évidemment à
vous de me rectifier vous avez fait ces
déclarations en fait non pas sur la base
d'informations particulières que vous
auriez eu comme ancien
diplomate et ambassadeur en Russie mais
sur les affirmations que vous disposiez
comme citoyen français qui lis la presse
et qui suit l'actualité et de vos
discussions avec d'autres ambassadeurs
sur des rumeurs des informations qui
étaient elles-mêmes soit connue par la
presse soit
comment dire le l'exemple de l'audition
des services du directeur des services
allemands que vous avez mentionné n'ayez
pas d'autres informations
ça me permet de préciser cette question
et elle s'arrêterait là parce que dans
vos dans le verbatim que je me suis
permis de vérifier vous dites que vous
faites ces déclarations à responsabilité
c'est vrai que excusez moi j'ai dit je
prends mes responsabilité de citoyens
c'est pas la même chose suivant si vous
avez raison je vais prendre mes
responsabilités
ma question et cette ce mot peut avoir
créé dans ce qu'il a entendu parce que
ça a comme créer un émoi à l'époque bon
toutes les dans beaucoup de familles
politiques un mémoire relatif en
convient absolument
que par responsabilité vous parliez
intéressé
ambassadeurs donc est-ce que vous pouvez
est-ce que j'ai bien compris les
déclarations que vous avez fait dans vos
propos liminaires monsieur Président
vous avez bien compris vous pouvez me et
j'espère que ce sera clairement
retranscrit quand je dis je prends mes
responsabilités je veux dire en tant que
citoyen
je précise à tous mes interviews que
d'ailleurs j'ai arrêté de faire que je
suis à la retraite que je langage
personne d'autre que moi-même et que je
ne suis pas un chercheur mais que je
suis moi et que je parle de ce que j'ai
vu donc je prends mes responsabilités ça
veut dire en tant que citoyen en gros je
dis tout haut ce que d'autres pensent et
ne veulent pas dire bien
d'où venait ce qui était à l'époque mes
impressions je sais plus si c'est le mot
que j'ai employé
personne n'ignorait oui alors quand je
dis personne je reconnais que là il y a
un peu d'exagération j'ai précisé la
communauté diplomatique un certain
nombre de journalistes excusez-moi un
créditer localement
avion des doutes sérieux voilà bon pour
dire les choses clairement si j'ai cité
le patron du renseignement allemand le
président de la République ou le
témoignage de Monsieur chafoseur quand
même membre du Front national c'est pour
simplement dire que comme sa corroborait
quand même me semble-t-il c'est un
corroborer l'impression que j'avais à
l'époque et c'est vrai que du coup je me
sens ne pas avoir dit des choses
particulièrement
original pardon de le dire comme ça
alors j'aurais dû préciser évidemment
d'où venait mes impressions pas
seulement du fait que il y avait
beaucoup de voyages de représentants des
Front national ou qui venait pas me voir
mais je parlais quand même à beaucoup de
Russes
je n'arrive qu'une ancien cagibi ce
président de la Douma francophone
Président je crois de l'association de
la Légion d'honneur à l'époque
aujourd'hui patron des services de
renseignement extérieur russe qui s'est
fait de penser publiquement à la
télévision par le président Poutine pour
son échec
en termes de renseignement en Ukraine je
parlais au célèbre monsieur slowski
je parlais à Monsieur Pouchkov président
de la commission d'affaires étrangère je
faisais mon métier de diplomate
et je vous assure qu'il ne mâchait pas
leur mot sur le soutien qu'ils avaient
apporté un certain nombre de gens
c'est pas moi qui est invité Marine Le
Pen au Kremlin c'est pas moi qui ai
diffusé cette image
donc quand j'ai appris effectivement le
prêt
excusez-moi j'ai fait le rapprochement
peut-être à tort il se trouve qu'entre
temps les révélations d'un organe de
presse ont montré que je m'étais pas
trompé mais encore une fois moi je n'ai
donc l'oreille contre personne j'ai fait
simplement une impression
qui était liée à mon travail de
diplomate j'ai quand même fait ce métier
de 40 ans je pense que je sais un peu
lire le comportement les comportements
et les mots et je vous assure que ces
russes que je vous ai mentionnés je les
ai mentionnés notamment parce que
c'était
le tiercé francophone des institutions à
l'époque il cachait pas leur sympathie
pour ce parti politique
comme le président Poutine le cachait
pas quand il recevait un centre
d'interlocuteurs
je le savais j'étais ambassadeur je
parle à mes collègues
il me parlait je leur parlais
nous nous écoutions mutuellement
c'est un secret pour personne de dire
que la France et l'Allemagne était sont
des pays extrêmement proches qui
travaillent beaucoup ensemble
d'ailleurs la chancelière et le
président Londres travaillaient ensemble
à l'élaboration du compromis de minks
donc nous parlions beaucoup de ce qui se
passait avec l'ambassadeur de Belgique
avec les ambassadeurs de des pays de
l'Union européenne bon nous échangions
nous racontions ce que nous pouvions
raconter sans compromettre les intérêts
de nos propres pays on se raconte pas
tout évidemment enfin la coopération
européenne c'est un sens nous sommes une
depuis le traité de Lisbonne 2009 une
communauté d'intérêts de valeurs
donc nous nous parlons donc j'ai forgé
cette impression
cette impression voilà si les mots ont
été impropres dans ma bouche devant les
médias
soyons clairs c'était une impression et
il se trouve qu'elle n'a pas été
démentie
entre le moment où j'ai eu cette
impression et le moment où j'ai fait
cette déclaration et je redis encore une
fois que quand j'ai dit je prends mes
responsabilités c'est en tant que
citoyen en tant qu'homme
c'est justement pour établir les choses
précisément les trois personnalités
russes dont vous avez parlé
c'est une question qui vient à l'esprit
quand vous en parlez on peut imaginer
que la même manière qui raconte
n'importe quoi sur le régime russe sur
l'histoire de l'Ukraine ou l'histoire de
la Crimée ils peuvent aussi non mais
c'est ce qui m'inspire parce que vous
avez cité ces trois personnalités vous
pouvez imaginez qui vous raconte c'est
pas forcément faux on peut aussi
imaginer que c'est pas forcément vrai et
après on sera madame la porte
vous avez raison
mais enfin simplement pour dire les
choses honnêtement non non très
honnêtement les déclarations
convergentes
de l'intelligensia russe du clan Poutine
pour dire les choses clairement des
hommes de Poutine en faveur leur espoir
de voir la candidate d'extrême droite
française élue ne faisait aucun doute
pour personne personne n'a jamais pensé
que que Moscou souhaitait la victoire de
l'autre candidat
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur pour la clarté et
la franchise de vos propos
je vous donne acte d'avoir répété et
confirmé même si
il y a pu y avoir ici ou là quelqu'un
interprétation
sujette à caution mais je vous donne
acte d'avoir répété et confirmé les
propos que vous avez tenu sur LCI à
l'ami septembre 22 et dans lequel très
clairement vous vous dites vos
impressions entre guillemets mais
étayées par 40 ans de pratique et
d'expérience et diplomatiques que des
hommes et les femmes politiques français
d'un certain bord venait à Moscou et ne
repartait pas les mains vides et vous
nous avez dit très clairement à
plusieurs reprises que cette expression
certains bords pour vous sans aucune
ambiguïté se réfère à des représentants
et représentants de l'ancien parti Front
national
je vous remercie aussi d'avoir comment
dire en préambule de de vos propos sur
le sujet des ingérences interférences
influence étrangères qui est l'objet de
cette commission d'enquête rappelée
ce que ce qu'est l'objectif actuel
poursuivi l'objectif politique sur le
plan international
par la Fédération de Russie et par le
régime de Vladimir Poutine à savoir
affaiblir la démocratie et que du coup
ça interroge effectivement je reprends
vos propres termes je partage cette
interrogation sur la rationalité de de
certaines et certains et notamment des
Français d'autres Européens donc
appartenant ayant la chance d'appartenir
à des pays démocratiques sur le soutien
sans faille apporter au régime en place
au Kremlin je voulais poser une question
vous avez vous-même fait allusion
au fait que Madame Marine Le Pen a été
reçu au Kremlin par Vladimir Poutine
très précisément le 24 mars 2017 soit un
mois tout juste avant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle française
[Musique]
quand l'avez-vous pensé est-ce que cela
est
habituel qu'avez-vous pensé de cette je
prends mes responsabilités moi aussi là
en tant que femme politique et citoyenne
française de cette adoubement donné par
le Kremlin Madame Le Pen à un mois du
1er tour de l'élection présidentielle
française
écoutez j'ai dit moi-même en train de
faire mes cartons puisque je suis parti
au mois de juillet 2017 donc je faisais
des allers-retours avec Paris mais en
tant qu'ambassadeur je n'avais rien à
penser encore une fois c'est pas illégal
de se rendre en Russie et c'est pas
illégal de rencontrer qui on veut en
tout cas pas le président Poutine enfin
donc elle elle était pas la seule à être
super plaisant Poutine enfin de se le
dire ce n'est pas grand monde mais
ce n'est pas les ministres
il recevaient les premiers ministres
pour une rencontre de courtoisie en
général en marche des séminaires
intergouvernementaux évidemment les
présidents donc c'était inhabituel mais
je n'ai enfin moi je n'avais pas de
jugement à porter j'imagine enfin
honnêtement je me souviens pas mais vous
voyez c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose
qui m'a particulièrement marqué parce
que
comme je l'ai indiqué j'avais déjà
l'impression que c'était un parti qui
cherchait le soutien du Kremlin et je
voudrais préciser une chose quand j'ai
dit ne repartez pas les mains vides ça
voulait dire ne repartait pas sans
obtenir le soutien qu'il cherchait ça
n'implique pas nécessairement toujours
des questions d'argent on parle aussi de
soutien politique justement de mise à
disposition des réseaux
par prendre l'épisode que raconte
chaffozère sur les échanges de
communiquer que le Kremlin essaie
d'écrire de faire écrire qu'il réécrit
lui-même dit-il fièrement je ne les ai
pas laissé l'écrire je l'ai écrit
moi-même bon
donc le soutien c'est ces multiformes je
ne sais pas obsédé par ces questions de
financement il faut pas bon voilà et je
ne pense pas que Marine Le Pen soit
reparti avec un chèque dans son sac
c'était pas du tout la question ce qui
était surprenant c'était que le
président Poutine reçoive un leader d'un
parti politique parce que
traditionnellement quand tu es une
élection présidentielle un leader
étranger soit il reçoit les deux
candidats ça arrive souvent qu'il ne
reçoivent aucun candidat au premier tour
puisque nous avons la plupart du temps
beaucoup de candidats au premier tour
mais en général d'abord c'est rare que
des candidats aillent chercher du
soutien à l'étranger parce que c'est pas
forcément bien vu en France mais dans
mon souvenir les devants dans les pays
où j'étais en tout cas les présidents ou
le chef d'État qui recevait des hommes
politiques étrangers c'était plutôt soit
les deux soit personne soit ils
attendaient l'élection il recevait le
nouvel élu ou la nouvelle élu enfin
voilà donc c'était surprenant de la part
du Kremlin
alors voilà bon c'était un choix qui
avait fait le Kremlin se soutenir
officiellement et publiquement Madame Le
Pen moi j'ai pas apporté jugement là
dessus mais c'est pour ça quand on me
demande encore une fois pour sur quoi je
basais mais mes impressions c'est
évident que quand vous voyez ça vous
vous posez pas vraiment de questions sur
le fait que un parti chercher le soutien
de Moscou et l'obtenait en sous qu'elle
commence à se traduisait j'en avais pas
la moindre idée mais
voilà
merci avec votre autorisation on se
présente je voulais relayer le 2
questions que notre collègue Charles
zidsonstool qui ne peut malheureusement
pas être présent parmi nous cette
après-midi qui vous prie bien vouloir
l'excuser aurait souhaité
poser à Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
il s'agit de questions effectivement
vous avez déjà fait allusion mais c'est
l'ambassadeur mais au
assez remarqué entre guillemets
déplacement d'un centre de d'hommes
politiques français en Crimée après
l'annexion illégale en violation des
règles du droit international et des
traités qu'elle avait elle-même signée
par la Fédération de Russie de la Crimée
et de Sébastopol
là encore juste pour qu'on
je sois sûr d'avoir bien compris en tant
qu'ambassadeur de de France donc
jusqu'en 2017 vous n'étiez pas
systématiquement informé au préalable de
ces de ces déplacements et peut-être pas
d'obligation mais ce sont des choses que
vous pouviez se déplacements
représentant élu député par exemple vous
pouviez les apprendre incidament il n'y
avait pas forcément une information
préalable
monsieur Maryline n'avait pas téléphoné
pour me dire qu'il irait en grimé voilà
après en regardant la télévision russe
c'est c'est très clair effectivement
est-ce que de manière générale par de là
les noms des quelques personnalités
russes que vous avez cité donc président
de groupe d'amitié
récifrance de la Douma ou autre
personnalités
qui étaient habituelle je dirais dans
les dialogues franco-russes je ne fais
pas allusion la fameuse association dont
nous avons longuement à connaître lors
de notre audition il y a deux jours de
Monsieur maliani mais disons le voilà
les échanges entre la Russie et la
France est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
noms de de personnes de personnalité
d'autres personnages ou d'autres proxis
enfin Sénacle qui vous avez parlé de la
Chambre de commerce franco-russe mais
peut-être d'autres sénacles d'autres
officines qui
dont le rôle serait avéré dans la
construction de de relais de relation
notamment avec certains partis
politiques français ou européens
encore une fois madame la député je suis
ni
chercheur ni universitaire et je
travaille en fait pas du tout sur ces
sujets ces derniers temps je vous l'ai
dit je travaille sur le la protection
des enfants dans les conflits armés donc
ça va pas grand chose à voir
moi j'ai pas dressé un tableau je vous
ai cité les principaux avec lesquels
j'avais un interface pendant que j'étais
ambassadeur
il y avait certainement des tas d'autres
associations elle ne passait pas par moi
est-ce que c'était
parce qu'elle faisait pas besoin de
soutien de l'Ambassade parce que ne
souhaitait pas un soutien de l'État ou
parce qu'elle n'avait pas confiance
compte tenu des propos que je tenais
parce que je suis quelqu'un qui a
toujours dit ce qu'il pensait quand
j'étais en fonction bien entendu dans le
respect de mes instructions c'était
c'était clair
j'ai pas dressé une liste mais il y a
énormément d'associations si vous tapez
sur Internet association
franco-russe ou française et enfin qui
travaille au dialogue francorus vous
allez en trouver beaucoup il suffit de
chercher les noms de leur responsables
pour voir tout de suite quels sont
celles qui sont manifestement financées
par d'autres
mais ça
moi c'est pas mon travail n'est pas des
d'abord montrer c'est pas de savoir ce
qui se passe en France c'est j'étais
ambassadeur j'étais pas là voilà
mais il y a des dizaines de gens en
effet qui faisaient du lobby que je peux
pas citer tout ce serait pourquoi
privilégier plutôt que l'autre mais
c'est l'ingérence c'est subtil quand
l'association
Normandie Yémen
très belle association qui honore la
mémoire de ces pilotes français de ces
mécaniciens russes et pilotes
qui se sont battus côte à côte ensemble
dans les mêmes avions
sur le front russe entre guillemets
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
nous célébrons chaque année au cimetière
de les forteaux
nous allons sur la tombe du dernier
survivant il reste un mécanicien russe
je crois
il est peut-être mort depuis un bon père
porte vous avez des écoles Normandie
Yémen
une petite fille en uniforme je vais les
voir bien sûr faut payer son respect
puis elle apprennent le français
mais quand les tarus s'invite pour faire
une enfin l'utérus ou ses démonsbrements
invitent toutes les familles des
descendants de normandie-néaines à faire
une tournée en Russie
voilà
c'est pas de l'ingérence mais c'est
sûrement de l'influence
et je me souviens j'ai évidemment offert
un cocktail à la Résidence d'autant qu'à
la résidence pour ceux qui n'ont pas été
il y a des photos sur le mur du général
de Gaulle des Corans
à l'époque en 44 les survivants du
groupe normandie-némen vous savez
Staline l'a fait attendre pendant 9 mois
9 jours pour signer le fameux traité
comment il s'appelait d'amitié où je
sais pas quoi franco-rus après la dans
44 et donc il a décoré les gens de
Normandie-Niemen mais les photos partout
alors je les ai invités évidemment tous
ces descendants et au fond c'était assez
drôle parce que c'est des gens qui au
fond pour beaucoup d'entre eux n'avaient
jamais mis les pieds en Russie et qui
amenaient leurs enfants pour découvrir
la Russie c'était extrêmement émouvant
ça n'était pas sans idée sans
arrière-pensée bien sûr de l'un de l'un
des autorités russes en même temps
je dirais c'est de l'influence dans un
sens
qu'on peut pas contester enfin il me
semble c'est pour ça que j'ai accepté de
les voir mais ce genre d'opération avec
des associations plus ou moins étranges
avec des noms étranges
voilà j'ai noté pendant que j'étais
notamment ça m'avait frappé quand même
beaucoup de voyages organisés alors je
sais plus partir ça franchement je
comprends pas oublier
de descendants de ce qu'on appelait les
Russes blancs
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une forme de
volonté et là encore moi je de faire
redécouvrir ce qu'ils appelaient la
Russie nouvelle aussi la Russie
fantasmée de Vladimir Poutine et autres
dougines de l'affaire visiter aux
descendants des Russes blancs qui
avaient malencontreusement cru que
c'était l'Europe qui allait les l'Europe
occidentales étaient leurs futurs vous
connaissez la théorie de monsieur
doughin qui était le
penseur de la divin Poutine sur le grand
tsunami qui allait ravagé l'Amérique et
le fait que nous avions tort de choisir
l'Europe Atlantique face à l'Europe
continentale
je le dis d'une manière polie parce que
c'était beaucoup plus échevé que cela ce
qu'il me racontait
donc il y avait cette volonté de faire
découvrir la Russie nouvelle bon bah là
encore c'est de l'influence
nous soyons honnêtes beaucoup de pays
ils font on invite les Américains ont un
programme d'ailleurs qui s'appelle les
personnels yangliners non quelque chose
comme ça nous ça s'appelle je me donne
c'est le programme français s'appelle
pas les personnalités d'influence
justement d'avenir oui c'est ça mais
c'est quoi les personnalités venir c'est
des personnes qui ont choisi dans les
pays où on est comme étant susceptibles
par amitié pour notre pays et qui ont
envie de coopérer avec la France de
défendre des positions pas éloignées des
nôtres en tout cas bon
mais c'est sûr que de la part de régime
comme la Chine et là et la Russie c'est
évidemment une échelle et puis c'est
financé sur des fonds publics vous avez
une extraordinaire association de
l'amitié des peuples étrangers ou je ne
sais quoi à Pékin dans un immeuble où
vous avez 200 personnes qui sont payées
pour travailler à ça ce genre de trucs
inviter des gens tous azimuts tout le
temps de partout etc donc là c'est sûr
que c'est les pays qui mettent de
l'argent
donc on peut dire que c'est de
l'influence
pas acheter mais mais financer
merci oui c'est toute la difficulté de
l'exercice consistant à bien définir et
distinguer l'influence l'interférence
l'ingérence mais effectivement la nature
démocratique ou non démocratique des
pays concernés et examinés à même déjà à
regarder les choses d'un
œil plus ou moins rassuré si je peux me
permettre cette expression une dernière
question toujours en lien avec ce que
Charles
avait envisagé
d'aborder
vous avez ce titre en tant
qu'ambassadeur de France en Russie eu en
permanence des liens étroits avec vos
homologues des autres pays de l'Union
européenne a commencé par l'ambassadeur
d'Allemagne bien évidemment sur tous les
sujets qu'on a évoqué notamment celui
d’établi à la liste des sanctions des
personnes sanctionnées etc etc et c'est
bien normal
vous avez dit aussi que vous échangiez
peut-être sur
l'inquiétude qui était partagée commune
sur les risques les menaces et une
stratégie d'orchestration d'ingérence à
destination de plusieurs pays de l'Union
européenne
est-ce que vous avez souvenir de
conversation précise avec telle ou telle
de vos homologues peut-être
l'ambassadeur d'Allemagne en Russie ou
un autre sur justement les cibles
politiques les cibles en tant que
mouvement ou parti politique qui dans un
autre pays que la France aurait été
particulièrement l'objet d'attention et
d'intérêt et donc de
d'accompagnement soutenu
incapable de répondre à cette question
avec des années d'écart et par ailleurs
je peux pas mettre en cause des citoyens
étrangers donc ce serait étrange de ma
part
non j'avais une relation particulière et
extrêmement développée et c'est
j'allais dire constitutionnel ce serait
absurde mais c'est constitutif de ce
qu'est l'Union européenne aujourd'hui
avec l'ambassade d'Allemagne et
l'ambassade de l'Union européenne
notamment parce que c'est dans ce format
ce triomphe viral que nous organisions
beaucoup de nos opérations à destination
de la société civile
notamment en matière de défense et de
promotion des droits humains ce qui a un
prix franco-allemand des droits de
l'homme par exemple
que nous remettons en même temps que le
prix
des droits de l'homme français par la
République française donc on proposait
des candidats ensemble bon
donc on essayait de soutenir ceux qui
dénonçaient eux-mêmes ces pratiques
inquisitoriales d'ingérence ou
d'influence du Kremlin
mais ça c'était vraiment Chine aussi
l'Allemagne et l'Union européenne c'est
naturel alors surtout dans des pays où
notre poids économique est fort ou en
tout cas nous voulons qu'il soit fort
celui de l'Union européenne je parle
et oui évidemment l'Allemagne fait la
course en tête
du point de vue économique je rappelle
d'ailleurs que quand même quand j'y
étais ou même encore récemment l'Union
européenne c'est le premier partenaire
économique et commercial des trois
grandes puisses ce qu'on oublie un petit
peu souvent quand on parle de l'Union
européenne Chine aussi alors peut-être
c'est moins vrai aujourd'hui avec la
Russie parce que quand tu les sanctions
je sais plus très bien où on est le la
balance commerciale euro russe mais
enfin à l'époque avant les sanctions
avant l'agression contre l'Ukraine voilà
donc naturellement on vivait ensemble si
vous me passez l'expression alors on
faisait aussi des tas de coloc parce que
je vous je pourrais parler le forum
économique de Saint-Pétersbourg lieu
d'influence on invitait un certain
nombre de patrons
le d'ailleurs le Kremlin avait créé un
Conseil international où il avait nommé
des patrons de grandes entreprises
étrangères pour le conseiller sur la
politique économique
quand il allait à Davos avait beaucoup
d'y aller ou quand il allait au spif
partant au Forum de Saint-Pétersbourg
il recevait ses chefs d'entreprise
qu'évidemment était très honorés d'être
reçu par le Chef de l'État
qu'il soit français allemand Belgique
italien portugais
ok vous avez dit pardon vous avez des
choses très intéressantes mais là je
laisserai peut-être ma collègue Anne je
t'aime et rebondir sur le fonctionnement
et l'état d'esprit de communauté et des
communautés françaises en Russie ou en
Chine les microcosses très particuliers
voilà moi je voulais simplement voilà
vous dire que vous aviez souligné
l'intérêt que porte la représentation
nationale au sujet des ingérences
étrangères que ça fait quelques mois que
nous travaillons la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement dont je
suis l'un des membres d'une structure
interparentaire composé le 4 députés 4
sénateurs je dis aussi pour les
journalistes qui suivent nos travaux
travaillent mais certes de manière
extrêmement confidentielle pour ne pas
dire secrète depuis de nombreux mois sur
le sujet des ingérences étrangères et on
a eu d'autres occasions il y a eu un
rapport au Sénat aussi sur le sujet mais
vous avez raison la prise de conscience
doit aller maintenant crescendo des
risques et des menaces
monsieur bayou
oui merci beaucoup
pour ce propos liminaire et je m'excuse
pour le retard je le regret d'avoir raté
le début peut-être le début de vos
propos luminaires et je vous remercie
vraiment pour votre présence et votre
franchise
je sais pas comment vous réussissez le
tour de force d'être à la fois
nuancé et prudent et pour autant
sans langue de bois
[Musique]
pour être parfaitement clair j'avais sur
la base de vos propos et d'autres
éléments notamment Mediapart et autres
papiers que j'avais
envoyé un signalement au procureur de la
République
donc j'ai pas forcément à dire grand
chose de plus ici sur le sur la suite
qui qui est engagé mais je voulais vous
le dire en transparence moi j'ai
plusieurs questions alors je sais pas si
je dois les mettre tout à la filet ou
ben écoutez vous avez cité le Front
national on le rassemblement national et
donc c'est pas évident dans une c'est
pas anodin dans une commission qui est
présidée par un de ses membres
et dont on peut penser on peut
s'interroger sur l'objet de cette
commission qui est au nom de dire que le
sujet est passé
pour pas tourner autour du sujet est-ce
que selon vous un prêt d'une banque
russe
aux Front national ou au rassemblement
national est-ce que ça représente une
forme d'ingérence pour le démocratie
ça c'est la première question la plus
directe
deuxième est-ce que ces allers-retours
liés à un financement est-ce que ça peut
alimenter une une influence une
dépendance
est-ce que ça a un lien avec certaines
des positions qu'on peut être prises
alignées sur celle du Kremlin on va dire
notamment est-ce que ça peut avoir une
influence dans la présidentielle 2017
vous disiez un moment c'était sur un
autre sujet mais on peut supposer que
quelqu'un lui a demandé
sur la reconnaissance du référendum
d'annexion de la Crimée ou par exemple
cette résolution qui était portée par
nombre de gens de parlementaires de
droite sur la levée des sanctions
imposées je cite lever des sanctions
imposées par l'Union européenne à la
Russie
est-ce que c'était voilà selon vous
téléguidé influencé conseiller suggéré
et puis dernière question mais qui fait
le rebond par rapport à la question de
Madame la rapporteur en tout état de
cause est-ce que pour vous c'est un
problème qu'un
parti soit financé à l'étranger est-ce
que ça affaiblit la diplomatie française
est-ce que ça affaibli votre position
quand vous avez dit que vous n'étiez pas
prévenu quand des parlementaires
[Musique]
venez sans vous prévenir est-ce que ça
met en difficulté une ambassade quand il
y a des relations directes entre un état
et un parti si vous n'avez pas informé
la réponse à vos trois premières
questions va être extrêmement rapide ce
n'est pas à moi de prononcer
quand j'ai cité le Front national je
rappelle que c'était à la demande en
réponse à une question du président qui
m'a dit de qui parlez-vous comme j'ai
juré de dire la vérité j'ai
dit ce que c'était c'est pas moi qui
l'ai dit spontanément sinon je n'aurais
pas parlé à LCI comme je l'ai fait donc
je c'est pour dire que je ne vise pas
moi je fais pas de politique quand je
vais essayer
donc j'ai répondu une question du
Président j'ai mis un nom puisque cela
m'a été demandé
est-ce qu'il y a une forme d'ingérence
ou pas excusez-moi mais là c'est au
juste de le dire c'est pas à moi
chacun a son avis sur la question moi
j'ai pas d'avis enfin je veux dire je ne
sais pas
vu que 15 ans à l'étranger je n'habite
pas en France depuis enfin j'habite en
France de nouveau depuis 3 ans j'ai vécu
22 ans à l'étranger 15 ans d'affilée je
suis rentré en France il y a trois ans
où j'ai fait complètement autre chose
pendant 3 ans
par cette déclaration qui me vaut être
ici aujourd'hui
j'ai fait beaucoup d'autres choses
donc je pensais tout juste de le dire
est-ce que ensuite le fait d'être reçu
par un président conduit à l'alignement
j'aurais tendance à vous dire mais là
c'est plutôt
litote dire que c'est plutôt peut-être
parce qu'il y a alignement des positions
que les gens se rencontrent enfin j'en
sais rien
c'est le président Poutine a reçu Madame
Le Pen c'est peut-être parce qu'il
pensait qu'il pensait la même chose
j'imagine enfin j'en sais rien
franchement je peux pas me mettre dans
la tête de la lumière Poutine
contrairement à ce que ce bon monsieur
de geminov mais ni dans celle de Marine
Le Pen cher j'en sais rien moi j'estime
j'ai pas enfin ça me en tant que citoyen
j'ai pas d'idée sur la question j'ai
simplement comme citoyen
constaté y compris
après la guerre d'agression déclenchée
en 2009 que pendant plusieurs semaines
voire plusieurs mois
des représentants
et de l'extrême droite de l'échiquier
politique c'est un jugement c'est le
classement bon de la droite et de
l'extrême gauche on continue à défendre
les tests traditionnels sur le fait que
la Crimée était ruse que Poutine n'avait
pas de tort ensuite certains ont dit la
des tort mais vous en nous en avons
aussi toujours pas compris lequel enfin
bon bref j'ai mis j'ai constaté ça donc
voilà est-ce que ça veut dire que ces
gens étaient sous influence non on peut
leur faire crédit de penser qu'ils
pensent ce qu'ils disent
alors sur la deuxième question c'est un
vrai sujet pour les pour les
ambassadeurs
j'ai reçu
une délégation menée par un président de
région
après l'adoption des sanctions j'ai fait
une réception comme à chaque fois on a
fait un briefing il est allé aux
entretiens d'ailleurs j'ai dû
l'accompagner probablement une fois ou
deux on a fait les débriefings et puis
on finit par un pot dans la salle de
l'ambassade de France Moscou et il fait
un discours où il critique le
gouvernement français
devant des Français devant des Russes
à l'ambassade de France
ça c'est gênant parce que ça donne le
sentiment à nos interlocuteurs et là
j'aurais pu citer n'importe quel pays
c'est moi
dans une ambassade de France critiquée
quand on est un élu la politique du
gouvernement d'abord c'est mettre en
difficulté l'ambassadeur puisque
l'ambassade n'est pas censé avoir des
positions on est dans un sens ni dans
l'autre ça ça fait partie de la
déontologie du métier en tout cas
publiquement et deuxièmement ça donne le
sentiment ça ça
transmet l'idée qu'il y a plusieurs
positions françaises donc ça ça
affaiblit le gouvernement
enfin le gouvernement au sens la
politique officielle du de la France et
donc du gouvernement pour dire la
politique officielle du de la France
quel que soit le gouvernement
une visite qui est pas prévue
non
quand un député va soutenir un dictateur
qui lâche des bombes chimiques sur son
propre peuple comme ça a été documenté
pour le président Hassan
avec le soutien de l'aviation russe
et alors que la France une fois n'est
pas coutume puisque c'était une
exception
dans la tradition française avait rompu
ses liens diplomatiques avec le
dirigisme
vous savez que c'est un cas unique la
France a rompu avec le régime de Bachar
el-Assad sous le président Hollande pour
reconnaître la Coalition nationale
syrienne comme le seul représentant des
peuples syriens c'est une exception dans
je crois le principe de non
reconnaissance
des gouvernements de la France
ça c'est gênant pour la position
française alors c'est pas gênant en
Syrie parce que le président
Alassane il sait très bien que c'est pas
parce qu'un député vient déjeuner chez
lui que ça va changer la position du
gouvernement français
mais c'est l'image
qui est désastreuse
d'ailleurs ça vous renvoie la question
précédente est-ce que l'image d'un
leader politique recevant un chef
politique d'opposition dans n'importe
quel pays d'un certain pays à un
problème j'ai envie de dire en
démocratie non
puisque nous pensons précisément que les
gens doivent être libres on peut trouver
ça désagréable on peut critiquer mais on
reconnaît au présent Poutine le droit de
recevoir qui veut puisque nous voulons
que notre président ait le droit de
recevoir qui veut
c'est plutôt dans les dictatures que ça
gêne comment vous avez reçu le chef de
l'opposition comment vous avez reçu le
dalaï-lama si ça vous rappelle quelque
chose de la part du régime chinois alors
on fait pression sur pression comment
encore aujourd'hui ce matin aux
Américains vous allez recevoir la
présidente taïwanaise et elle va faire
escale à New York ça n'est pas
acceptable donc c'est les dictatures qui
refusent nous est-ce que ça nous fait du
tort à Moscou j'en sais rien parce que
moi je suis pas dans la peau des
Français de mais en France je ne sais
pas si ça a fait du tort à qui que ce
soit en tout cas
pas la démocratie enfin je ne crois pas
donc voilà quand on n'est pas prévenu on
sait pas quand on sait pas
mais c'est vrai qu'on découvre parfois
un bon vous me dites ça mais j'ai reçu
la semaine dernière monsieur ou madame
machin qui m'a dit le contraire c'est
pas grave pour un ambassadeur mais
je vais vous dire quelque chose qui ne
vous surprendra pas et
je pense que quand on est un ambassadeur
faut pas avoir d'ego
le service public avant tout
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur de votre
vos longues explications et riche
j'ai beaucoup de questions mais je vais
essayer de les faire les plus brefs
possibles
tout d'abord pour éclaircir un point qui
reste relativement ambigu même si je
pressant la réponse vous avez précisé
que vous voyez le même phénomène à Pékin
que à Moscou concernant en tout cas un
parti politique qui se montrait plutôt
présent mais qui ne pensait pas
nécessaire de ce signaler à l'ambassade
est-ce que vous pouvez indiquer quel est
ce parti s'il vous plaît
je crois qu'à propos de la Chine j'ai
parlé d'hommes politiques
d'un autre bord pour pour montrer que je
n'avais pas de querelle avec un bord
particulier j'ai parlé de Monsieur
Raffarin je pense que son parti
politique est connu j'ai mentionné le
président de la commission du groupe
d'amitié je crois franchine de
l'Assemblée nationale précédente son
affiliation politique est connue je sais
dire je suis honnête je suis même pas
sûr je la connais c'est c'était lui
personnellement qui m'avait surpris par
les propos qu'il tenait donc je suis pas
sûr de son affiliation politique mais
moi je
comment dire
oui non c'était des personnes si vous
voulez et puis c'était pas un appareil
de partie je serai pas honnête en disant
ça si c'était un appareil parti je le
dirai
je vous remercie ça clarifie je pense
que c'est aussi un des enjeux de cette
commission d'enquête d'essayer de
déterminer l'ampleur du problème de
votre propos moi je retiens
on revient en fait à des distinctions
qu'on a entendues par ailleurs il faut
faire entre l'égo la sotise la naïveté
de certains acteurs leurs conviction
leurs intérêts et je crois que avec les
convictions on voit émerger la question
de la convergence intellectuelle
politique ou idéologique et d'autre part
et c'est là sans doute le problème la
question des intérêts il y a la question
qui va se poser de la transaction de la
réciprocité et on entre là dans le
domaine de
dans un domaine où la légalité va être
questionnée
je note aussi ce que vous dites de la
singularité de ces de ces régimes
dictatoriaux
et de leur stratégie la désinhibition à
l'égard du droit international et
l'ampleur des moyens que les accorde
dès lors la question que je me pose est
de savoir
quel genre de relation on doit avoir
avec ces régimes parce que il y a des
questions des sujets stratégiques
des projets que nous avons en commun
avec ces régimes
longtemps après qu'ils aient franchi la
ligne rouge si vous me passez
l'expression je peux donner des exemples
quand en 2020 il y a mal LNG donc le
terminal de GNL
est mise en œuvre ça fait longtemps que
il y a pourtant un froid c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire diplomatique avec la
Russie
quand nos partenaires et amis du golf
finances des organisations que nous
éprouvons mais que néanmoins nous leur
vendons des armes ou que tout simplement
ces régimes
massacrent leur population ou les
réprimes on peut s'interroger sur
la sincérité ou sur le caractère de
réciprocité de transactions qui existent
soit entre les acteurs soit entre les
États
et qui justifie en réalité ces choix
politiques donc j'aimerais savoir est-ce
que vous
vous seriez me donner un indice de à
partir de quand on doit pouvoir
questionner ce choix politique voilà je
suis un dernier exemple sur la question
du mécénat
on a des acteurs qui sont se présentent
comme entrepreneur de cause et
on peut quand même s'interroger sur la
sincérité de leurs engagements sur leurs
éventuels arrière-pensées on a quelques
milliardaires
[Musique]
américains ou pas d'ailleurs qui crée
des fondations et puis qui deviennent
présidentes et fondations
internationales pour la préservation du
patrimoine qui finance des bourses etc
etc au cœur de l'État français qui sont
décorés par le ministre des Affaires
étrangères est-ce que on n'a pas là
aussi une question de savoir est-ce que
le caractère officiel de la chose est
pas problématique néanmoins et
symptomatique d'une transaction
monsieur le député pour vos questions
mais je ne suis pas un homme politique
je suis pas non plus étrangères je suis
un diplomate à la retraite donc mon avis
ne vaut que celui d'un citoyen ordinaire
avec un peu d'expérience
mais je suis pas savant sur ces
questions
sur le mécénat parce que pour moi c'est
le plus facile je peux pas encore une
fois parler de la France moi je suis pas
j'ai passé ma vie entière
41 ans dans les relations
internationales aux Nations unies à
l'Union européenne en France enfin avec
la France et car 22 ans à l'étranger
donc je suis pas très qualifié pour
parler de la situation en France ce que
je peux dire pour les associations que
je préside notamment ou dont je suis
administrateur c'est que nous sommes
dotés de charte éthique
[Musique]
que normalement il y a aujourd'hui des
règles de responsabilité sociale des
entreprises
il y a quelque chose des Nations Unies
qui s'appelle le Global Compact ou les
entreprises prennent alors c'est sur une
base volontaire des engagements en
matière éthique pas faire travailler les
enfants etc
que probablement certaines entreprises
violent j'en sais rien
donc ça c'est une ligne de conduite en
tout cas pour le secteur informel et
nous y sommes très sensibles nous en
parlons entre nous entre associations
pour s'y tenir
du point de vue du gouvernement encore
une fois vous êtes c'est législateur qui
doit dire au gouvernance qui peut faire
ou ne pas faire je peux pas en parler
sur
votre première votre deuxième question
en réalité c'est la même jusqu'où
doit-on continuer à avoir des relations
avec des pays avec lesquels on a des
désaccords fondamentaux qu'ils explosent
si je puis dire
en un conflit ou pas
c'est toute la difficulté
des responsables politiques
comment préserver une relation avec la
Russie parce qu'on ne choisit pas ses
voisins que la Russie est un pays
extraordinaire moi j'aime la Russie
j'aime les Russes l'histoire le peuple
la culture c'est extraordinaire comme la
Chine
je pense juste qu'il méritent mieux que
la lumière Poutine mais c'est l'ordre
soit pour autant qu'ils en ait
donc la Russie sera toujours là et tant
mieux
et donc bien sûr en tant que diplomate
c'est évident que je pensais toujours
pensé que il fallait
préserver ce qui pouvait être préservé
au-delà des désaccords sans se trahir
soi-même
il faut être ferme sur ces valeurs ne
jamais concéder et
je crois que j'ai une réputation qui est
dans cette pas être quelqu'un qui sait
de facilement sur ses valeurs on me l'a
suffisamment reproché
passer des sur ses valeurs mais essayez
de comprendre là où il y a possibilité
soit d'influencer vers la paix vers le
retrouver une relation normale
c'est ce qui s'est passé à Bénouville en
juin
quand le président Hollande a proposé un
président pour Jenko président Poutine
et à la chancelière de former ce groupe
de Normandie
pour essayer de trouver une solution au
Dombasle pas la Crimée il n'était pas
question de négocier sur la Crimée dont
nous ne reconnaissons pas l'annexion
donc il faut essayer
et puis il y aura pas de sécurité en
Europe sans évidemment un accord entre
d'une part l'Union européenne d'autre
part la Russie
et ceux qui joueront un rôle sur la
sécurité dans le monde au moment où on
en sera là donc probablement encore les
États-Unis
mais ça veut pas dire avec la Russie de
l'univers Poutine qui a montré qu'il ne
respectait aucun traité signé on peut
comprendre que ça donne quelques doutes
que ceux que vous avez beaucoup posé
d'ailleurs nos amis de Pologne et des
États baltes nous n'avons pas écouté
moi j'étais surpris depuis février 2022
devant la surprise d'un certain nombre
de gens de quoi était-il surpris
tout avait été dit écrit et fait par
Vladimir Poutine à une autre échelle
le bombardement des maternité le
l'utilisation d'armes chimique on l'a vu
en Tchétchénie on l'a vu pas pour les
armes chimiques pour les bombardements
aveugles on a vu en Syrie
quoi de nouveau
l'annexion par la force on n'est pas
encore vu les enlèvements d'enfance
c'est nouveau
mais donc à l'intérieur de cette
difficulté il faut préserver les
relations dans un avenir éventuellement
lointain
il faut éviter le pire mais il faut pas
se compromettre ben c'est le rôle des
parlements des ministres et des
présidents d'arbitrer de louvoyer
peut-être
vous avez pris l'exemple de Yamal je
suis pas sûr que ça soit un bon exemple
parce que il y a mal c'est un accord
entre deux entreprises privées
comme vous le savez total et un total
énergie aujourd'hui et Novatech qui est
la plus grande compagnie
russe privée
privé au sens russe on peut pas dire que
son patron ne soit pas proche du pouvoir
parce qu'on n'est pas un grand patron en
Russie si on n'est pas proche de Poutine
mais enfin bon privé avec des capitaux
privés et donc c'est un risque privé qui
a pris total et par ailleurs le
gouvernement français n'a pas les moyens
d'interdire à Total d'effectuer un
investissement en Russie de l'axe légal
ce serait très étrange enfin ou alors là
faudrait adopter des lois et ça c'est
votre rayon c'est pas le mien
pour ce qui est de l'État vous auriez pu
citer la vente des frégates
dès l'invasion de l'Ukraine le président
Hollande a décidé de suspendre comme
vous le savez la livraison des deux
bâtiments de projection et de soutien
les BPC en disant je peux pas livrer des
bâtiments de projection un état qui
vient d'en envahir un autre
il y a eu des discussions nombreuses moi
je travaille pas le secret de la
confession ou si je travaille tant pis
pour moi j'ai tout de suite dit au
président de la République qui a eu la
gentillesse de me demander mon avis
comme ambassadeur que évidemment il
fallait pas livrer
c'était pas la vie dominante dans la
communauté ni des affaires ni des
vendarmes ni diplomatique mais bon tout
le monde s'est fait d'ailleurs ce sujet
bien compris ça s'est pas trop mal fini
enfin bon donc faut pas confondre les
relations d'état des détails je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure on a continué la
relation de coopération contre le
terrorisme heureusement
souvenez-vous de tout ce qu'on a vécu
d'ailleurs
2013 2014-2015 on n'a pas manqué de 2016
2013 2015-2016 on n'a pas manqué
d'attentats terroristes
et
les réactions du régime russe même si on
était en mauvais termes le soutien du
peuple russe nous a pas fait défaut moi
j'ai vu des queues de centaines de
mètres de mon ambassade de russe qui
venait pour témoigner leur solidarité
donc c'est une question de balance c'est
ça c'est au décideur de le décider
en revanche je pense que ça a
certainement conduit à forger cette
conviction que l'Europe devait
rechercher ce qu'on a appelé l'autonomie
stratégique
que ce soit au début on parlait surtout
d'armement on parlait de sécurité on
parlait de défense mais aujourd'hui on
voit bien après le covid après tout ça
qu'on parle de d'autonomie stratégique
dans le domaine sanitaire dans le
domaine alimentaire dans le domaine
énergétique dans le domaine
technologique je ne sais pas quelle cité
c'est à dire que l'Europe devient enfin
une vraie puissance disposant toutes ses
capacités de manière justement en cas de
désaccord fondamentaux à ne pas être
dépendantes de ces intérêts stratégiques
enfin on a vu dans l'affaire de
l'énergie que finalement peut-être je ne
sais pas comment ça finira mais on
pouvait même se défaire de cette
dépendance là
une dernière question sur une deuxième
juste par information on va devoir lever
la séance pas trop tard ensuite parce
que madame le rapporteur serait assez
agréable obligation et c'est vrai que la
séance est déjà à 2h30 mais vous pouvez
poser votre question et après et si vous
pouvez Monsieur l'Ambassadeur dans la
limite de ce qui est possible parce que
pour le coup il commence parfois y avoir
des redites mais c'est non mais c'est
normal c'est l'expression humaine c'est
l'expression humaine normale qui nous
arrive à tous sur une longue durée si
vous pouvez dans la mesure du possible
être plus concis dans vos questions dans
vos réponses pas
la dernière question porte pas forcément
sur un cas très précis mais sur le
statut des entreprises et sur la façon
dont les entreprises peuvent participer
à une stratégie d'influence d'un gérance
ou de déstabilisation
vous disiez on peut pas être grand
patron en Russie sans être un proche du
pouvoir je crois que c'est également
vraiment en Chine est-ce que vous pensez
que nous sommes suffisamment lucides
face à la réalité des dessins et des
affiliations des grandes entreprises
alors on cite souvent les gafams mais
est-ce que vous pensez qu'on est
suffisamment lucide et doté même du
point de vue législatif pour faire face
par exemple au pantouflage d'un
directeur du Trésor qui rentrerait dans
un fond de preuve était quitty chinois
par exemple
là encore écouté en tant que citoyen
mais en tant qu'enseignant ambassadeur
c'est sûr que je remarquais
dans le même temps que je faisais des
séances de sensibilisation aux risques
quand j'étais en Russie en France des
entreprises des présidents d'universités
des patrons de labos de recherche de
centre je l'ai fait quand j'étais
ambassé en Russie et quand j'étais en
Chine quand je découvrais qu'un ancien
Premier ministre était au conseil
d'administration ou travailler ou un
ancien ministre pour
Huawei ou gastrom j'étais surpris
qu'on puisse ne pas réagir alors encore
une fois faut s'entendre Huawei il
s'agit pas des téléphones
Huawei des téléphones Apple ou des
téléphones je ne sais pas quoi ce sont
les infrastructures de communication les
centres de formation et les leur
exploitation qui est en cause
j'ai souvent expliqué vous tracer une
carte des endroits où les chinois au nom
de la fameuse initiative ceinture et
route
installe des relais radios des centres
de formation
et contrôle les organisations et les
installations de radio Diffusion et vous
avez une courbe parfaite entre Djibouti
et le Cap Vert qui vous donne une idée
précise de ce que recherche les Chinois
c'est ça le problème
alors sur gaz Prom c'est plus compliqué
parce que le prix du gaz et la
dépendance de l'Europe au gaz russe
était telle que en effet là il y avait
possibilité où on pouvait avoir le
l'impression ou le soupçons que tout ça
n'était pas très net
les gars femme vous l'avez mentionné
c'est clair mais je pense
qu'effectivement dans la société
française qui n'a pas peur des
contradictions on vous explique à la
fois qu'on doit pouvoir faire ce qu'on
veut et en même temps que l'État doit
nous protéger donc il n'y a pas de
protection contre l'influence étrangère
les ingérences
et les manipulations de l'information
sont mobilisation de la société pour moi
c'est une évidence donc le législateur à
son rôle à jouer certainement
est-ce qu'il faut durcir la législation
sur moi je vous dis je me suis
auto-appliquer je travaille que pour
l'État donc
je refuse de travailler pour des
intérêts privés
est-ce qu'il faut durcir allonger les
périodes peut-être je ne sais pas si
c'est une grande efficacité parce que
vous pouvez toujours donner des conseils
à qui vous voulez
est-ce que vous n'allez pas aller
surveiller tous les contrats de tous les
organisations de conseil qui
appartiennent à d'anciens aux
fonctionnaires hommes politiques enfin
je sais pas il doit y avoir des
centaines non ou des milliers moi j'ai
aucune idée j'ai jamais fait ça de ma
vie donc je ne sais pas
qu'on soit plus stricte quand on le
découvre en revanche des
relations de transactionnelles comme
vous disiez j'aime bien le mot ou des
relations tout simplement donc des
prises illégales d'intérêt ça je pense
qu'il faut être il faut être beaucoup
plus ferme ça certainement mais il faut
former les Français à l'intelligence à
la sécurité au renseignement
c'est pas un sujet tabou c'est pas un
sujet dégoûtant c'est pas parce que
c'est des méchants américains des
méchants russes ou des méchants chinois
parce que ça peut être n'importe qui je
vous assure qu'il y a des pays qui sont
pas en reste et c'est pas forcément des
pays auxquels on pense
je ne sais pas vous voyez ce que je veux
dire moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on fasse
un effort collectif oui et là la loi
peut certainement nous aider
moins que font les commissions là qui
est auditionnent les hauts
fonctionnaires j'en sais rien mais il
faut pas non plus s'en prendre qu'au
fonctionnaire parce qu'ils ont pardon de
le dire mais en France ils ont un peu
ils ont un peu bandeau les
fonctionnelles vous pouvez avoir été un
dirigeant d'une d'une entreprise qui a
eu des contrats avec l'État tout de
votre vie ou qui vit essentiellement sur
des contrats d'État et vous aurez la
même influence
ou dans le dans le milieu culturel je
veux dire donc c'est là que c'est
difficile parce que comment vous tracez
des limites pardon j'ai été trop long
monsieur j'ai fait
dans la mesure du possible plus serré
possible merci le président monsieur le
Président je vais essayer d'être
synthétique merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
je vous remercie d'avoir clarifié vos
propos tenus sur LCI notamment sur le
fait que vous exprimez en tant que
citoyen et uniquement sur des
impressions et sans preuves je vous cite
parce que sur LCI j'ai vérifié vous
laissiez quand même planer un doute vous
aviez simplement dit je prends mes
responsabilités je suis à la retraite ce
qui laissait pleine à un doute sur des
informations que vous pouviez
éventuellement détenir dans le cadre de
vos fonctions mais je pense que vous
avez éclairci ce point vous me
contredirez si j'ai tort je voudrais
revenir tout d'abord sur le prêt accordé
je vous précise que les précédentes
auditions de cette commission notamment
avec la CNCCFP en charge de la
vérification des comptes de parties ont
mis en avant que le prêt accordé par une
banque russe au Front national je cite
encore a été fait dans des conditions
bien plus défavorables que n'importe
quel prêt que le parti aurait eu dans
une banque française je rappelle aussi
ce que de cette question aujourd'hui ne
se pose plus puisque c'est prêts sont
désormais interdits par la loi dans ces
conditions est-ce que selon vous ce prêt
entretien de vos déclarations pas
reparti les mains vides parce que
évidemment ça n'est pas tout à fait la
même chose de parler d'un prêt autorisé
légal et valider par les autorités de
contrôle français que de financement
illégaux comme certains auraient pu
comprendre votre déclaration et que je
ne sais quelle valise d'espèces ou autre
je continue toujours concernant cette
émission
sur LCI le président Tanguy n'avait pas
tout à fait tort quand il a dit que vos
déclarations avaient suscité de les mois
puisque dans cette même salle en
commission des affaires étrangères le
président de la commission monsieur
bourlange a indiqué qu'il allait vous
adresser un courrier de demande
d'explication sur vos déclarations alors
ma question est-ce que vous avez reçu ce
courrier et est-ce que vous avez répondu
à ce courrier
merci
si j'avais eu la preuve de quoi que ce
soit j'aurais fait un article 40 je suis
fonctionnaire je l'ai été pendant 40 ans
je n'ai jamais été condamné pour quoi
que ce soit je n'ai jamais été même
traîné devant une commission
disciplinaire je connais le respect des
lois c'est la beauté de mon métier je
l'ai assumé bien donc je n'ai jamais
prétendu avoir des preuves j'ai
d'ailleurs dit dans un autre interview à
BFM ou dans le même un peu plus tard
bien entendu je n'ai pas vu de chèque je
crois que j'ai dit ça textuellement donc
on peut découper ce que j'ai dit et
faire mon procès c'est si vous voulez
c'est je crois que c'est pas ça le sujet
j'ai répondu j'avais une impression je
l'ai mentionné et quand j'ai dit je
prends mes responsabilité encore une
fois ça voulait dire je suis citoyen je
suis diplôme à la retraite je dis ce que
j'ai à dire bien est-ce que le prêt a
été fait des conditions favorables ou
défavorables j'en ai aucune idée est-ce
que c'était constitutif de quelque chose
je n'en sais rien mais je rappelle que
j'ai cité et je vous ai je vous demande
de vous y reporter de nouveau les
déclarations de ce chaffozer qui a
reconnu avoir touché de l'argent sous
forme de commission
140 à 400 000 euros pour négocier auprès
du Kremlin le fameux prêt
il y a une enquête du parquet sur le
sujet donc c'est encore je ne fais que
répéter des choses qui ont été dites
publiquement
pardon alors sur la lettre de Monsieur
Boulan bourlange pardon alors
effectivement elle est arrivée avec un
certain retard pour des raisons que je
connais pas et qui n'appartiennent pas
de de commenter mais je vais être très
franc avec vous je connais bien monsieur
Bourlon je l'ai souvent reçu dans les
postes où j'étais
ambassadeur c'est un homme courtois avec
qui je me suis toujours très bien
entendu en tant qu'ambassadeur mais ça
n'était pas un courrier qui me demandait
quoi que ce soit
c'était un courrier vous l'avez donc je
pense que vous l'avez tous qui me
reprochaient un certain nombre de choses
voilà qui me rappelait l'article 40
je ne me sentais pas particulièrement
concerné
et qui m'expliquait que mes propos
allaient faire l'objet
de suite judiciaire
je ne vois pas très bien en quoi je
pouvais que pouvais-je répondre à
Monsieur bourlange
j'ai appris ensuite assez rapidement la
création de cette commission
je reconnais n'avoir pas douté un
instant que vous feriez appel à mes
services
et j'ai donc décidé que je répondrai à
la Commission comme la loi m'en fait
obligation et comme je suis tout j'étais
tout à fait prêt et désireux de le faire
mais je vous assure si vous lisez cette
lettre que à aucun moment il me suggère
de lui répondre
merci Monsieur non effectivement on a je
vous confirme qu'on avait on était pas
Imposs possession de de ce courrier donc
je ne pouvais pas en connaître le
contenu mais peut-être effectivement que
si vous rappelez l'article 40 c'est
justement parce que vos propos à
l'époque laisser planer quelques doutes
et encore une fois je vous remercie de
les avoir clarifié devant nous
aujourd'hui
une deuxième question vous avez affirmé
également en début cette édition qui
avait un seul parti qui a refusé de nous
rencontrer à l'ambassade lors de ces
voyages à Moscou vous avez aussi dit que
vous n'aviez dans la plupart des cas pas
connaissance à l'avance des voyages
prévus alors la question est est-ce que
vous avez formulé effectivement des
demandes de rendez-vous à qui et qui les
aurait refusé et est-ce que d'autres
élus d'autres partis qui ont fait des
voyages à Moscou ont accepté ces
demandes de rendez-vous
alors j'aurais dû être plus précis bien
entendu quand je recevais des
délégations parlementaires par exemple
ou régional ou municipal j'avais
probablement
tous les partis
du 10 conseils municipal du 10 conseils
régional
du conseil général ou du dit de la dit
de commission au groupe d'amitié
donc de ce point de vue là je pourrais
dire que j'ai reçu tout le monde
on parlait des voyages bien sûr
individuels
ou uniquement d'un groupe particulier
si j'ai cité celui-là
j'ai rappelé d'ailleurs que pour la
Chine j'en avais cité d'autres
en réponse aux questions du Président si
j'ai cité celui-là c'est parce que c'est
le seul souvenir que j'ai en tête
que d'un d'une visite pour laquelle nous
avions pris contact avec l'attaché
parlementaire ou le député lui-même pour
lui proposer nos services comme à tout
le monde et qu'il avait refusé voilà
c'est tout donc je le mets en cause je
j'aurais pu mettre en cause d'autres
parties si j'avais eu connaissance
d'autres d'art je l'aimais pas en cause
je dis en fait je leur ai proposé mes
services ils en ont pas voulu c'est en
fait c'est pas une mise en cause
chacun est libre de faire ce qu'il veut
personne vous fait obliger à faire
obligation un homme politique de rentrer
en contact avec l'ambassade nous nous le
suggérons parce que ça permet de faire
des briefings on donne des dossiers on
leur organise même des conférences de
presse souvent dans les locaux de
l'ambassade enfin je pense que certains
d'entre vous en ont bénéficier partout à
travers le monde c'est notre travail
donc encore une fois moi je portais
d'accusation contre personne j'ai dit en
fait
je suis honnête je me souviens plus très
bien un peu pas avec certitude de la
date de la visite en question et du nom
du député mais ça m'est resté
comme il y a eu beaucoup de voyages
je pense que c'était monsieur choprane
si vous voulez avoir un nom mais je suis
pas tout à fait sûr parce que moi je
prends pas des notes toutes les trois
secondes de ce que je fais
mais il y a eu beaucoup de voyages y
compris par d'autres encore une fois
donc simplement c'est celui là je me
souviens que nous avions proposé nos
services c'est qu'on les a refusé c'est
la seule chose que j'ai dit
que sur ce sujet là j'entends
merci beaucoup une dernière question
très rapide que vous avez déjà répondu
au député saint Toul vous avez aussi
affirmé au début de l'audition j'ai des
doutes sur d'autres personnalités
d'autres bords politiques sur des
voyages effectués en Chine
quel personnalité encore une fois vous
vivez par ces déclarations et sur vos
doutes est-ce que vous parliez de
soutien politique ou de financement
politique ou simplement des impressions
comme ce fut le cas sur le cas russe il
me semble que Monsieur l'Ambassadeur a
répondu et la réponse est vous la
connaissez je l'ai dit trois fois si
j'avais eu des preuves j'aurais fait un
article 40 je n'en avais pas j'avais des
impressions qui étaient liées notamment
à mes discussions avec eux mais c'est
vrai que dans le cas de que j'ai cité du
président de la commission du groupe
d'amitié ou de l'ancien Premier ministre
il me parlait
dans le cas précédent comme on m'a pas
parlé je peux pas dire que j'en ai parlé
voilà
merci l'ambassadeur monsieur
pèse sur tout le monde le pour sans
vouloir passer trop de temps très
rapidement une question qui m'est venue
puisque je prends la parole au début
c'est vrai que les réponses et les
autres questions suggèrent à mon esprit
quelques quelques questions
sous une fois plus qu'on faisait en
particulier en Russie parce que les les
Lavaux que les gros contrats en Chine
sont moins connus mais vous avez bien
signifié que c'était pas forcément un
soutien les réseaux les réseaux russes
ne visaient pas forcément un soutien
financier mais un soutien politique
général et quand même aussi peut-être un
soutien et il faudra voir votre action
là-dessus sur les affaires les affaires
économiques et un certain nombre de
grands contrats vous avez répondu sur
total mais il y en a d'autres ont eu
lieu en particulier soit leur soit la
réalisation de ce contrat la signature
de ce contrat pardon soit leur mise en
place au lieu notamment quand vous étiez
ambassadeur et qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
dire sur les
d'influence de réseau qui permettent la
mise en place de ces contrats gencives 1
qui a partie lié avec l'État il s'agit
des contrats de la société GDF Suez
engie avec des infrastructures qui sont
quand même importantes puisqu'il s'agit
des deux gazoducs
nurstream nos stream 1 sur lequel
engie avait GDF Suez à l'époque avait 9
de mémoire entre 9 et 10% du capital
puis 9 10% c'est très peu je vous laisse
à votre appréciation mais c'est une part
importante dans le droit de vote quand
même et
sur North stream 2 également une
exposition un investissement à hauteur
d'un milliard pour le celui-là a été
signé a été signé en juin 2015 engie
avait aussi au-delà de ces
participations sur ces deux gazoducs une
participation enfin à droite tirage sur
Yamal
avec Novatech comme vous l'avez comme
vous l'avez indiqué engie pourrait vous
le savez pour ceux qui nous écoutent à
le capital de l'État dans engli sous
cette place ou cette période où ces
contrats évolue entre 18 et 25 % selon
les périodes donc l'État a à partir dans
les décisions aussi stratégiques
évidemment d'investissement dans des
infrastructures aussi stratégiques or
vous savez que bon c'est vous l'avez
d'ailleurs vous-même que ce ces
infrastructures enfin vous avez pas
notifié comme ça mais on peut estimer
que les deux gazoduc reliant l'Allemagne
à la Russie en outre passant de passer
par nos autres partenaires européens la
Biélorussie et l'Ukraine a créé une
dépendance directe de notre continent à
la Russie donc quel pour vous est-ce que
vous avez eu connaissance
des réseaux ou des discussions de
l'exécution de ces contrats comment ça
se passait du en Russie
autre type de de contrat quand même même
totale énergie évidemment vous l'avez
dit une entreprise privée mais enfin
c'est une entreprise c'est la première
entreprise française une entreprise qui
se dirigeants sont comme en contact
réguliers avec l'État
et justement est-ce que vous total à des
contacts avec l'ambassade ce qui vous
informe de ces activités ou pas du tout
et autres questions pour pas perdre trop
de temps
il y a une personnalité quand même qui
notamment aide enfin était censé aider
les relations économiques avec la Russie
entre 2012 et récemment c'est Monsieur
Jean-Pierre Chevènement qui est nommé en
2012 à une fonction de représentant de
la France en Russie pour notamment les
dossiers économiques et Monsieur
Chevènement reçoit quelques mois après
votre départ comme ambassadeur une
médaille de amitié avec la remise par
Monsieur Poutine où il a des
déclarations
particulièrement enfin c'est traduit du
russe moi je ne parle pas russe donc
c'est traduit par la presse
en signifiant monsieur Poutine signifie
clairement je me souviens et entre
guillemets de la notion d'action
concrète que monsieur levénement a fait
danser dans ces métiers qui lui
permettent de recevoir la Une des plus
hautes distinctions russes des mains
directs de Vladimir Poutine donc est-ce
que vous aviez en plus des relations que
vous avez déjà fait des réseaux que vous
avez déjà donc vous avez déjà informé
vous avez déjà caractérisé ce que vous
avez conscience confiance pendant
connaissance de cette de cette autre
type de travail et ce qu'il y avait une
diplomatie parallèle de Monsieur
levénement de l'ambassade c'est une
question c'est pas une question piège
c'est une question totalement neutre de
savoir à quoi correspond en fait cette
fonction qui me paraît un peu pas
forcément clair pour les observateurs et
extérieurs pardon
merci monsieur le Président sur la
deuxième question
c'était l'héritage de je ne sais plus
quel président qui avait créé des
ambassadeurs pour les pays
importants et on a commencé avec 5 il y
avait la Chine la Russie je ne sais plus
l'Inde on avait nommé l'ancien ministre
François Poncet je me souviens il y
avait bon donc c'était cette idée que
les ambassadeurs n'étaient pas en
capacité notamment en France de
mobiliser l'ensemble des acteurs qui
pouvaient développer la relation
bilatérale et que donc avoir des anciens
hommes politiques ou des hommes
politiques pour pour porter plus haut la
voix de la France était utile j'ai eu
avec le Jean-Pierre Chevènement les
mêmes relations qu'avec Jean-Pierre
Raffarin c'est-à-dire excellente sur le
plan personnel j'ai coopéré à toutes
leurs missions j'ai aidé à organiser
leurs entretiens officiels
et je n'étais pas d'accord avec voilà
donc mais ça ne veut pas dire que je les
soupçonné de quoi que ce soit tout le
monde sait les positions qui a pris la
fondation
tous les cas tout le monde sait les
positions de la fondation de Jean-Pierre
Chevènement où les positions de la
Fondation
prospectives et innovation de
Jean-Pierre Raffarin j'ai pas besoin de
rentrer dans le détail donc
il défendent des positions qui sont un
tout petit peu
différente de celle du gouvernement
français qui donc quand j'étais
ambassadeur était ma Bible comme c'est
le que normalement pour un ambassadeur
disons que ces deux représentants
spéciaux avaient des affinités pour
lesquelles on les avait sans doute
choisis pour leur connaissance de ces
pays mais qui les emmenaient disons à
une certaine forme
de difficultés à voir la réalité sociale
de ces pays
mais je n'ai jamais évidemment été
témoin d'aucun acte là encore qui aurait
pu te conduire à des
compromissions à des relations
transactionnelles ou à des conflits
d'intérêt enfin sinon j'aurais une fois
de plus ou des prises illégales
d'intérêt fait un article 40 mais mes
désaccords avec eux étaient connus et je
n'ai pas plus été invité au colloque de
respecticains cocologue de la Fondation
prospective et innovation alors vous en
concluez ce que vous voulez
disons que je suis un peu connu pour mon
indépendance d'esprit alors sur sur les
grands les grands contrats là il faut
pas se faire d'illusions si vous en avez
le mot est excessif illusion mais il
faut pas se tromper sur le rôle des
ambassadeurs nous on peut faciliter
les rencontres la préparation des
contraintes on informe sur les
conditions de telle ou tel contraint le
contexte les personnes les circuits de
prise de décision c'est notre boulot on
fait du lobby autrement dit moi j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps à faire beaucoup
de lobbying
il y a certains secteurs qui font plus
appel aux ambassadeurs comme les
marchands d'armes comme vous le savez
parce qu'il y a encore une fois de
l'État très fort donc j'ai hâte ou
d'assaut c'est pas une entreprise
publique mais enfin sans l'État et bon
bref donc on voit intervenir beaucoup
mais dans les négociations elles-mêmes
nous ne sommes jamais associés
absolument jamais alors
soyons honnêtes quand un ministre est
passage surtout quand c'est un ministre
de l'économie et des finances
soit il amène ou un président parce que
lui pour le ou un premier ministre ils
amènent des chefs d'entreprise donc là
on arrive parce qu'on les connaît
finalement quand même à force à soutirer
quelques informations sur qu'est-ce qui
cherche à faire ou est-ce qu'il cherche
à aller on essaie de les convaincre
qu'on peut aider on est curieux donc on
essaie d'en savoir plus mais enfin on ne
joue aucun rôle enfin je crois que ce
serait prétend
on facilite voilà alors espérons qu'on
sert à quelque chose à un moment ou un
autre enfin c'est pas nous qui
participons négociation ça les choses
doivent être claires être informé expost
ça c'est autre chose
et vous avez mentionné total énergie et
Yamaha et je dois rendre hommage
à la mémoire de
[Musique]
monsieur de Margerie
quoi qu'on pense là encore de son
attachement à la Russie
c'était quand même un homme assez
exceptionnel qui avec qui finalement je
m'entendais bien parce que il ne cachait
pas non plus ses idées c'était quelqu'un
qui avait un franc parler donc on
s'entendait bien
il passait à l'ambassade
quand il venait négocier sur le l'avenir
de Yaman notamment
il me cachait pas les interrogations
qu'il avait sur le développement de la
deuxième partie du projet Yamani il
était assez réservé
et trouvait que la prise de risque par
totale était déjà forte c'était avant la
mise en service de Yamaha
voilà et c'était la dernière fois qu'il
est passé à l'ambassade c'était
quelques-uns en ce moment
puisque vous savez que
il est mort dans un accident à
l'aéroport de Monaco
donc il nous informait il envoyait quand
il n'était pas l'un son directeur on
avait de bonnes relations avec les gens
de engie sur Nord Stream souvenez-vous
du contexte monsieur le Président
c'était une opération soyons clairs
qui posait des problèmes pour les
raisons que vous avez dites parce que
tout le monde disait mais enfin
vis-à-vis de la Pologne et de l'Ukraine
c'est quand même pas et pas tant
encore que la Pologne finalement s'est
retrouvé parce que ça consistait à faire
une boucle mais finalement il s'agissait
surtout de priver l'Ukraine des
bénéfices du transit du gaz russe
c'était ça l'objectif plus
l'approvisionnement sécurisée de
l'Allemagne donc je crois comprendre ce
que j'ai compris c'est que la France
cherchait à avoir quelques autant de
pars qu'elle pouvait dans le marché je
parle de North stream 1 là pour le coup
puisque North stream 2 a donné vous le
savez lieu plutôt des oppositions
franco-allemandes assez forte parce que
justement on trouvait que l'un dans le
contexte politique ça devenait vraiment
tout à fait gênant je ne sais pas du
tout ensuite je suis parti je suis parti
en Chine donc c'est vrai que je ne suis
pas du tout occupé de ça génère
découvert le problème de North stream
que quand manifestement si j'en crois à
la presse les services russes ont
eux-mêmes fait exploser une gazoduc
très bien je vous remercie je suis
rapidement parce que j'avais pas du tout
pensé poser cette question mais la
journaliste en charge notamment de des
relations avec total de lifep
a publié un livre qui n'est pas du tout
qui ne nourrit je tiens à le dire pas du
tout les complots sur monsieur
Marguerite mais qui a remis en cause de
manière journalistique à informer c'est
une journaliste de l'AFP et qui est
toujours en poste d'ailleurs
la qualité de l'enquête justement russe
et comme vous étiez est-ce que vous avez
parce que là c'est quand même le premier
PDG français est-ce que votre
ambassadeur vous avez remarqué que cette
enquête posée problème sera ma dernière
question qu'ensuite désolé mais comme
vous l'avez pas pensé la poser
d'une certaine façon je vous remercie de
me poser la question parce que c'est
quelque chose qui a été très douloureux
à gérer
parce que en plus de Gilles de Margerie
vous le savez pas de Gilles excusez-moi
Christophe de Marjorie excusez-moi
les membres de l'équipage sont tous
morts et notamment une des hôtesses de
l'air dans le mari très vite soupçonné
ou soupçonné une forme de complot
le bureau enquête accident a été
immédiatement appelé il était sur les
lieux quasiment le lendemain l'ambassade
a été appelé dès l'accident moi j'ai été
réveillé au milieu de la nuit quand
c'est arrivé enfin très très tard le
soir
et je n'ai jamais eu de doute de la part
du bureau qui est accident que les
choses avaient été transparentes alors
je pense qu'il doit y avoir d'ailleurs
un rapport du Bureau enquête accident du
de la DGAC qui doit traîner quelque part
qui doit établir cela ce qui est vrai
et je
ma conviction
c'est que le
bureau enquête accident est arrivé à la
conclusion que c'était un accident et
vous le savez comme toujours avec une
chaîne de catastrophe
absolument incroyable un blizzard un
conducteur d'engins de déneigement sous
il se perd dans la neige le responsable
de la tour de contrôle s'en va il le
laisse à une stagiaire qui va depuis 3
jours elle panique plus personne ne sait
ce qui se passe
à trois secondes près l'accident aurait
pu être évité
ce qui a beaucoup choqué indépendamment
de cette sorte de complot auquel je vois
pas très bien qui aurait eu intérêt
Russie assassiné Christophe de Margerie
enfin bon
c'est que les sanctions n'ont pas été
prises et que fondamentalement les
parties civils ont mis en cause
l'aéroport de vnokovo les responsables
de l'aviation civile enfin cette chaîne
de commandement qui a fait défaut du
début jusqu'à la fin si j'en crois le
rapport que j'ai lu à l'époque
il y a eu aucune condamnation et là il y
a eu des pressions très fortes de l'État
russe sur les juges pour éviter que ça
arrive donc je crois qu'on a condamné
une peine presque symbolique le
conducteur sous
de l'engin de déneigement et c'est à peu
près tout donc c'est ça qui a beaucoup
choqué notamment les familles ce que je
peux comprendre
je vous remercie l'ambassadeur Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur et je vous remercie
vivement d'avoir rendu au mal
effectivement à Monsieur de Marjorie et
aux membres de ses équipages disparu de
manière tragique madame la rapporteur
vous avez une question société par des
éditions bah écoutez monsieur Bayou
écoutez merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
pour le votre
venue le temps que vous avez consacré le
temps long consacré à notre audition
voilà vous êtes qualifiés de marathonien
de l'audition là je pense que vous
l'avez bien bien remplie je vous
remercie évidemment les administrateurs
pour leur travail leur contribution la
presse pour sa présence
et je la séance est levée je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée